foreign
can you guys hear me
no one hears me
yes so yeah it's
there's nothing left
so yeah it's Zoom it's Zoom that's what
it is it's Zoom
I sent them emails I don't even I don't
even know if
yo
hey it's Zoom
all right
because now I hear everyone fine you
guys can hear me fine it's Zoom
can you hear me yeah I got you I hear
you fine
I hope has D ever used stream yard
it's simple he just joins and I and I
put him in I'm sorry guys normally we
have this stuff together but my zoom I
don't know what that's about like it
it's it's crazy
oh so we're live yeah hello
hello
I wasn't going to continue to mess
because when I got back into Zoom it was
doing the same thing
all right okay
all right I'm sorry guys this is all my
fault this isn't King this isn't Cog
this is my fault
I I don't I don't know why uh Zoom was
messing up that much
is it better yeah no it's it's way
better it was Zoom that's what was
messing up it was Zoom
okay let me assume the program is on the
mic Zoom the program because they say I
sound fine now
all right
levels uh on this because stream yard is
completely uh different
different and more basic it's super easy
yeah basically
audio
boost that audio up
close that down
all right so we're going to start
everything from the resep yeah yeah my
bad guys like that that's on me more
about it you win and you fixed it right
that's it it's over that's it
let's go show new goal everybody here we
can do we got all the super chats from
before right yes I have them I have them
all right cool so that way that
everybody that did donate or did show
love definitely will uh get the super
chats heard so we do apologize for the
first stream apologize we're going to
get right back to the second Stream So
as I started off before this is iron
Lords podcast 319. I know that number
and that number is good thank you for
showing up here this is the first time
you meeting us and seeing the realm
please understand this is not the normal
format we do have another host that's
not here he's getting well he's getting
out of the hospital today I want
everybody to show love to lower cognitos
please put your hands together give a
nice prayer for low Cognito and if you
know him reach out to him let them know
that you love him he's coming home today
kid is coming home so please send your
love I don't normally use that uh like
that but this is a serious situation
where you do show up all right thank you
all guys for coming back we have 276
right now so listen share this out let
everybody know that you're watching iron
launch podcast I'm your
let's get to these intros I got my two
co-hosts with me today we're going to
give you the best show that you possibly
heard in a long time first and foremost
this man needs no introduction the world
over he is the stealth assassin the man
with the plan the demolenko of the team
the holder of the purse this man right
now has definitely held the wallet in
line and holds the line for us keeps our
spending habits true Lord Sovereign
thank you thank you for the intro again
big shout out to the car getting out of
hospital today feeling much much better
I appreciate that man so yeah show that
love the [__] uh definitely definitely
needs it you need to we need to
understand that we are all of us all of
us we gotta rest when our body tells us
to rest and sometimes it forces us and
sometimes things just happen so but
thankfully he's he's he's better and
gonna be out of hospital later today
yourself I got a chance to look at this
man's schedule because I was trying to
plan things out for us right right I'm
like what is he resting
he's His Own Worst Enemy sometimes and
he knows that we've said that to him
like he's just like he's just he's a
beast he likes to you know make sure
that he's prepared for everything and so
that's much appreciated but sometimes it
runs you down yeah but the nutcase thing
was he just came back from Florida right
from the the the the guardian company
yeah right and then came back did a
podcast for Destiny and then uh finally
do did our show got prepped for the
Peter Moore stuff and then he was going
to go away this weekend had just passed
and then when he came back go right back
right I'm like
when I talked to him I talked to him
yesterday I said you do know
that flying getting in that little
compressorized tube and getting out that
takes a lot out of it it does yeah you
need to chill out a little bit you're a
little too beefy Paul
schedule's a little too beefy yeah why
have you been playing Lord Sovereign
Keeper of the purse yes sir so uh
there's one game that I don't think I
can mention yet that I just I started
um uh no you can't I I can mention it
okay if we're talking about the one that
they sent you to yes yes so I I played a
little bit of sea of stars
um so uh uh an homage to Chrono Trigger
and and RPGs of that time so uh I'm not
I'm not having to be remotely close to
finishing it by the time embargo comes
but I'm enjoying what I've seen so far
uh I never played the demo when it came
out I know the demo was right at the
start of the game and it was like it's
gonna let you just transfer it over but
I downloaded and never played it so now
I'm gonna have the opportunity to play
it and I'm enjoying it so far beautiful
game computer that's good so it's like
Chrono Trigger I love Chrono Trigger one
of my favorite Square soft games yeah it
is that Chrono Trigger is an old timer
uh so anything in that vein that is of
that same quality
oh yeah it's a special thing it's a
special thing so um yeah playing that
and also Starfield so and on Starfield
we will have more to say on Thursday we
will be in midair when the Embargo uh
lifts and we'll have something nice
that'll go live for you guys and we will
talk about it so that's what I've been
doing also I went to see uh the last
Voyage of the Demeter yeah uh uh uh
basically uh
a Dracula movie that talks about one
particular chapter in the Dracula novel
which is uh the Captain's Log when it's
when uh Dracula is leaving Romania and
going to uh uh the UK England and the
ship that takes him there and
essentially Dracula's plan to use the
ship crew as his meal
closer he did not plan to use the ship
through this this is what I'm I mean the
movie interpreted it one way I don't
remember from the novel I read a long
time ago I don't remember if his plan
was just to finish off the ship crew one
by one as they got closer so he kind of
measured it out I don't know I don't
think I have to go back and and see if
the actual thing was that he he went on
the ship prepared
he had his food source with him they
happen to remove his food source and got
that stuff called upon them bro
108 dragons but if you saw r r with the
Lords it's it's a patreon run show it's
on our patreon and I advise and uh
please go to our patreon go check out
the stuff we have a bunch of free stuff
up there now where we do talk about r r
on r r with the Lords we do talk about
the last Voyage of the Demeter we do
talk about Blue Beetle and The Soca show
so um go check that out we have a couple
other stuff up there that attic and I
react to the patreon is going to be
primary focused going forward a lot of
giveaways a lot of stuff happening there
but I saw the last Voyage of the Demeter
and I personally thought that uh they
did a great job in using Nosferatu as
that base vampire and then they use uh
you know to uh 2023 uh CGI as far as
getting him to look his best like yeah
and I'm glad that they took this
depiction of him that he's a beast but
they wanted you to know that he's a very
calculating cunning Beast he's not a
stupid animal that you're about to face
and don't be fooled by thinking it that
way because you definitely not going to
survive this encounter so it was a great
movie to me yeah it was great I enjoyed
it again I haven't seen the Dracula
movie in a while and one that comes that
takes directly from the novel right so
yeah I love that
um but yeah yeah that it was very good
it was very good just to clarify chat I
sound fine right yes
it was on there and it wasn't on our end
oh no they will tell us
don't worry they have no you but I just
heard a little bit of like static yeah
yeah or something hopefully it's nothing
all right and the young wolf of this the
guy that has played and has forgotten
more RPGs than than I can remember
the difficult game conqueror this dude
right here has no chill button when it
comes to playing these wonderful RPGs
and actually getting things done my man
the heart and soul of IOP the new and
improved Lord addict what's going on
brother what you been playing I've been
playing a lot of Starfield and sea of
stars I think I'm actually close to the
end of sea stars
um you know so how do you do that
I I don't know how the hell because I
can't do this right how the hell I'm
like 30 hours RPGs at one time and these
are demanding RPGs how the hell are you
well after I put enough time into
Starfield I was like I can
I I've almost beat Starfield to a point
where I felt comfortable enough like
leaving so I was like all right let me
go back to let me go back to to see
stars because I have a real I have like
50 hours in Starfield so I was like let
me go back to see stars because that
embargo list first
yeah so you know I
I can't say much about sea stars
but if if I haven't played star foot I
would say this is my game of the year
okay nice it's a fantastic game yeah I
heard it was supposed to be good for
more noise Alex he was like yo because I
I like you know turn-based RPGs so he
was just definitely like this is coming
out and check it out
um yo black running 357. yeah my my bed
is not holding a lot ever since I
stopped it just for men
and you know I go get a trim and I just
you know shave my mustache off I got
something with my mustache that I can't
stand right
it had been growing so like God told me
to stop putting that chemicals in my
face and Lord Sovereign
and you know what it takes your brothers
to hold you to words that you said so
you know had to be a man of my word so
that's what it is
just if they would just give us one over
outlay on this on this that has the zoom
outlay I would prefer to use this one
over over I like how clean it looks oh
it looks really clean uh you know it's
funny I could switch to this one where
it like blows us up a little bit
you get a little bit more King how about
a little bit more close and personal oh
yeah we need a little beefy in this mode
we have played my joystick running all
over this song
myself the host King Lord King David
King of the statues I'm a dude that
loves uh premium things uh don't have
time to play games too much because I'm
walking working too hard but I
definitely get a chance to play NDA
games and I'm having fun with one NBA
game right now I know you guys want to
play it slow it's star Phillips star
feels fantastic
um what I've been playing this week
before I get to that
King chill
yeah yeah no no no no it ain't nothing
it ain't nothing
I wanna I wanna get to uh the fight that
uh happened this weekend
um
they have a fight over in England and
that is 6 p.m I'm not able to to throw
the fight on because I was doing RNR
with the Lords and I had to prep for R
and R with the Lords and we finally got
to get that done when I did pay for the
fight lost Sovereign You're gonna laugh
I was seven I was like yo maybe I could
set it up or get this done right
I was in round five when I tuned in
mm-hmm
I was like are you serious so that kind
of pissed me off
um he said breaking NDA twice no we're
not they everybody knows we're playing
Starfield they said we could talk about
it cut it out Hold the Line can't hold
the link y'all bugging
um yeah so that fight kind of pissed me
off I thought the boys dropped them and
I think that was like the seventh round
and probably won the fight but uh
hopefully uh we won't have this problem
well we definitely won't have this
problem when Canelo fights uh Jamel and
that's gonna be a good fight and that's
going to be a normal human times 10 p.m
Eastern Standard Time because they'll be
fighting in Nevada more than likely
um
besides that I'm really excited for this
week oh look at that room look at hold
on hold the line my boo boo just came in
give a shout out to uh
Lord Forte now I got to give Lord Forte
an intro
a friend like no other the brother holds
the line for sure he has been with us
since day one he is our destiny we play
Destiny and he's definitely one of the
raid Kings Sinister quiet don't be upset
Lord Forte how you doing today brother
man I'm good man look you know can't you
know we down one we we dial one horse
and um gotta come through and help out
when I can man can't replace that man
super um happy to be here with you guys
man and um it's incredible man you guys
are awesome and I love supporting and
being a part of it I love your setup bro
thank you your setup is my man showed up
and he's showing out I definitely love
that uh I love the visual always so
Forte what have you been playing this
week sir oh man well we all know the new
season of Destiny started I quit for
like a month because they got on my
nerves and then uh I jumped back in this
week but a little bit of that but mostly
Remnant too I've been playing that with
um The Ash and Luca and slo-mo been
having really really good fun with that
uh pretty much played the game three
times because you know in all their
Infinite Wisdom they like to not let
your progression go between characters
when you're playing with your friends so
that's what we've been doing and then um
also can't wait to play something that's
coming out next week that's gonna be
great but um yeah just kind of listening
to what you guys been talking about
um about your experiences in the games
that you know everybody wants to you
know jump into so that's pretty much all
I've been doing over the course of the
last week
okay that's what's up I mean so you
talking about Starfield that you looking
forward in the next week listen listen I
got I got that I got that constellation
Edition
listen I I told everybody was like
September 1st I will not wait I don't
wait to play games I have to play day
one and the only time that watch is
going to ever see the light of day is
the day that it that the day of
September 6th when the full release
comes out I'm gonna wear that watch to
the midnight launch and I'll be like yo
look I got a piece of the game on my
wrist and I can't wait to show that off
but um you don't have to work that day
or do you do you do midnight launches do
you like to do midnight launches from
where you uh absolutely I still love
doing them man some of the some of the I
mean you know some of the best things
you can do because you're it's just like
going to a movie right with like-minded
people you know people that want to come
out at midnight to pick up a game they
just like you they're excited just like
you so
um the last one we had was tears of the
kingdom and I had like close to 200
people there and it was incredible so
that's what I'm really looking forward
to so I know we're doing something like
that for that and then we got some other
ones in the lined up that's coming in
the future but um yeah I can't wait for
that one because I know a lot of people
are excited to get a chance to jump into
that game and play it I think that's
that's dope that you're actually out
there facilitating fun right you you
actually really on the front line
holding the line from when people come
in and they're seeing you and like you
are the most important person that
evening when you're checking them out
and you're giving them their stuff uh
yeah does it feel like Christmas to them
when you when you hand over this stuff
yeah this is the game it's like it's
like the gatekeeper man I had a customer
tell me he said man how does it feel to
be the gatekeeper of all these people to
get their game before they could go home
and I was like you know I never thought
about it like that but you know it's
cool you know people are just it you
know for the most part they're just
excited because they've been waiting for
games especially a game like this that
was you know a lot of rumors were last
year is supposed to come out now it's
finally here
um so yeah it's really really cool just
being a part of just the overall
Community the only thing that would make
this better if I was in your stomping
grounds in New York you know where where
the media is at where they got
full-blown parties and stuff for games
and stuff so if you was in New York in
in like the stores downtown and got
Times Square and stuff that's a party
party right I seen those parties online
and it's pretty incredible but you know
I'll keep my little piece of the of the
pie out here it's cool it's not as
impressive as you guys down there but
it's still cool no I'm in Westchester so
I don't get no I'll get the nice cool
relaxed you know before when we were in
the Bronx it was hectic they had police
outside yeah you know yeah but we were
going to Manhattan we were we weren't
trying to do midnight launches in the
Bronx they had it's a little dangerous
down there yeah I mean it's anywhere
like there's people Scouts I remember oh
yeah we went to get our 360s at um 86th
Street the uh GameStop there that's not
no longer there
um and that's just right that's a pretty
like well-traveled area well lit but you
come out there and you saw people that
was like um you're not here to buy a
console who are you watching
we were we went like seven deep eight
deep so we were projecting we were good
always yeah except for that one time
that was at the PlayStation 2 launch oh
yeah the PlayStation 4 PlayStation 3.
the one went mad and we slept on the
floor for Sony
yeah it was two I think there was
PlayStation two right that's PlayStation
two it launched it and that's when um
what was his name I forgot his name but
we locked our the key the keys all the
consoles was in his car remember we went
to go get a hot dog from papayas and we
came back and he liked the keys inside
the car we had to call a locksmith to
come and pop it open he charged us 75
and took five seconds and said but we
was all standing out in front of the car
we had to wait like almost two hours to
get the club for the lockers to show up
yeah I remember that man I think
everybody remembers their PS2 one man
PS2 was my very first like overnight for
a console wow I was um I was it was that
it was my first retail job I was at
working at Best Buy at the end I was a
warehouse manager right so I knew
how many PlayStations we had I remember
when they came in a week before palette
full of it was like 156 PlayStation 2s
right I was like oh boy it's like riff
out here so then literally the night
before it was like the most incredible
thing we had like literally people were
getting in line and they were like man I
don't know how many they got and I was
telling people I said listen as long as
you in the top 150 you good you're good
I said don't leave if you leave you go
you jeopardizing your spot but uh man
those that was incred like I got out
there at about six o'clock the night
before right we opened at nine the next
morning I've never had so much fun with
people like people outside racing each
other for games and stuff they was out
there passing out numbers getting each
other's
um phone number so they could like link
up after the fact yes that was a really
that was a really cool experience
the first time I saw for Madden the
launch Madden I forgot what number it
was it was the 360 Madden no the one for
the PlayStation remember when they had
the round helmets their helmets was
round and the eyeballs was black and big
and they had the little faces I remember
seeing them and I said this is it
because I mean 2K 2K didn't look like
real life kind of for some reason I
don't know what these little Madden
round helmet dudes was doing but it
looked incredible and I was just sitting
outside and I never forget that
anticipation and then I wanted to
remember I sold my ticket because I they
didn't take my ticket from me when I
went inside to get my PlayStation so I
came out and I sold my ticket for five
hundred dollars right so somebody got my
ticket with that ticket you had a number
on it so you was definitely inside I
went inside had my ticket in my hand
came out sold my ticket for 500 that
paid for all the stuff that I had so I
really got my PlayStation for free and
whoever got that ticket was able to get
a PlayStation but I know it probably
shorted somebody else on that line
because I already had got mine and and
we got home and that's that's the
two-hour wait when we stand outside that
that's what made it a little bit longer
because we was like we we survived let's
go get us some Graves papaya we did that
this dude I forgot uh cog's friend name
locked the keys inside the car and we
had to stay out there two hours the sun
started coming up by the time we was
getting home yeah the things you got
excited for back then it's crazy like
you know like you just said with Matt
and stuff yeah shout out to Madden
because it's like the it's always the
start of the holiday season for
everybody it's like when all the games
start coming out when you see Madden on
the calendar you know games are about to
start releasing because everything
starts coming week after week after week
after that it comes out the start of the
Fall it started to fall and I just
remember like with Matt like from PS2
Madden like remember the the little
things that they used to do back then
whether it was competition like there is
it now for Madden remember the reason
that you went out and bought a
PlayStation 2 to get Madness because it
was the first time that they had has
Stadium lights yeah in the game and it
was promoted all across the back of the
case it was like oh under real lighting
with the stadium lights all playing at
night and stuff and I was like oh I'm
super excited to play night games and
Madden you know there was no magnetism
before so now you can do it and little
things like that was the things that God
is super excited to play a new game and
you know compared to where we are now
it's completely different but I always
look back at those little fine little
things like that I love that I love
stuff like that I love seeing people
dressed up it felt like a little mini
Comic-Con for certain places that you go
to like if you was going to Manhattan
you saw everybody dressed up uh
participating we got 746 people here hit
that like subscribe share that out we
had a little technical difficulties in
the beginning but Forte showed up he's
holding down the beef line pause
done we're doing a little bit of
reminiscing but I want to get to our
super chats
um so we're gonna read the Super Chat
from the previous uh stream that was up
that got dropped and then we're gonna
read these super chats and then we're
gonna get into the show so uh Lord
Sovereign keeper of a purse please
enlighten us
we got Lord Star Killer Xbox series X oh
one twenty dollar Super Chat that PS
portal has no Bluetooth no Cloud
streaming equals the 200 paperweight
Series this series s can play the same
games as a series X uh bg3 split screen
for Series S can be added later we'll
see 100 plus games at 120 hertz not bad
for about three hundred dollars Max yeah
yeah we will discuss
then we got country big 94 with the five
pounds to protect currently sitting in
with 182 it was 100 with 82 000 other
people in Wembley Stadium shout out to
aew
filling out Wembley Stadium that's crazy
but can't miss showing my appreciation
for the Lord's having an amazing show
guys hashtag hold the line thank you
brother appreciate it
Robert Kelly two dollar Super Chat
blessed day Lords have a great show for
Cog a cogs beef shout out to you Robert
Kelly once again through those what's
happened for King how's the M classic so
far I also got the M Classics so King I
quickly
it's incredible it's it should be sold
in the Box whatever you switch
not those stand Stills all right don't
get it messed up I mean I'm talking
about a real switch the ones that
actually switch from handheld to uh
console it's it should be in the Box
every box should have an m-class yeah I
have it as well it and you could see it
in real time because it's just a switch
that yields back and forth like the
screen will go black for a second and
you can see it with processing it
without processing it's it cleans it up
a lot yeah like it's nice and it keeps
it nice and if it feels nintendo-ish
it's the product is so solid that it
feels nintendo-ish yeah if it's like a
baby's little baby spaceship but yeah
you know when it has to them like for
Mario that's what was blowing my mind
and the colors fit I was like these
dudes is on to something the Marseille
classic yes so it's it's pretty good
what was it 100 bucks King so it's no
it's worth it oh yeah well yeah because
we well yeah you picked it up yesterday
yeah yeah um so definitely it's a
definitely go if you if you want that
for your TV experience with the switch
or any other uh 360 any older consoles
like any four three consoles it has its
own type of processing as well and it
does a great job with that too so yeah
great great
then we've got Robert Kelly again five
dollars which I can't believe link made
that portable for Sony with the ultra
hand it's lacking PS plus clouds support
a huge l
we will discuss we will discuss all of
that
Robert Kelly five dollar Super Chat did
y'all hear 720p is the new normal again
fam Jedi and FF 1660 modes representing
2 and now Immortals the switch isn't the
only thing coming in hot
yeah yeah we've talked about the secret
sauce and how it's not being utilized
apparently
um
I think that's about that change though
yeah hopefully AMD let us we have MSR
three we got MSR three coming so we need
that PlayStation Pro
then we have necromancer's hail member
for 21 months Lord gold funny how I buy
new headphones with my Xbox from Odyssey
and the next day Sony buys them
hopefully I still get my Max my Maxwell
series headphones yeah they so yeah
Sony's gonna benefit directly from this
purchase obviously but so far they
they're still committed to making uh
headsets across the board and all these
are very good so yeah we got the um what
was that the rigs what came with the
rigs that program
[Music]
remember for three months Lord silver
yeah I was talking down on the switch
for so long only to be playing at 720p
on your next gen consoles oh how the
tables have turned hashtag join the
Vaseline game nah bro we still look
better than your joint if we're playing
a 720 you know where you playing right
240i oh man no not even Progressive skin
interlace
then we got the Doctor Strange Love five
dollars to be chat my thoughts and love
go to Cog hope he gets better we can't
we can't be having spoiled meat
shout out to Doctor Strange Love he was
getting a genuine concerned
people are blaming our technical issues
on my beard being gone yeah
the beard is the one that had all
detector detectors even the pirouette
your chair hasn't looked the same since
you cut the beard off
it was funny it's like when I was
talking when I was talking to my girl
she's like yeah because uh she wanted to
see me without a beard I was like well I
gotta shave it anyway and then when I
shaved it she was like oh that looks
great and I was like well uh my beard
will be back in like two weeks
yeah my wife was like oh I'd like to see
you without a mustache I know you won't
hear the picture and that ain't
happening
enjoy it yo I got those pictures of you
nah bro when I listen when I shave my
stash no no yeah my wife was like I love
how you said here's a picture
enjoy it was like uh when are you gonna
uh take this I said when hell freeze
over I said hey when when when I'm in
the casket before you're about to cook
me up right because I'm gonna be cooked
up cook me up cream made me and sprinkle
me over Madison Square Garden where all
the great fight has been uh then you'll
see my face again
I I kind of I never thought about that
until whatever recently for whatever
reason I got it in my head I'm like yo I
want to do the same like I don't put me
in a box and have me wake up oh nah bro
like you're going too far with that now
I just don't want to be used when the
zombie apocalypse come as you know
puppet on the front line like yesterday
I'm the mini boss yeah
you're the Boomer
money
the biggest feature I do love about
string yards is I could put chat and
super chats in in the actual picture
click it
all right then we have let me see four
is a legend remember for 44 Muslim
bronze full Spencer has doubled down and
said he's playing Remnant to a lot Lords
pick that game up and yes let's keep it
Xbox 100
uh King is actually playing again and
I'm gonna tell you this right now
that game hard as hell pause
um first one was difficult this one is
it's a part where I gotta defend against
spikes flying like arrows flying at me
hopping over something they hit you
twice you on your knees and by the time
you get up because I have this like to
get back into the fight perk by the time
you get up the next Arrow coming you
back down boy yeah like so I need
friends to join me usually my friends
are fortnite friends so when I say
something stupid like I'm gonna play
something else bye see you have a good
day
good luck over there
there we go let's put the Crush in the
chat for e-ranks Welcome to the round
Lord bronze thank you brother appreciate
that look at my guys so shady that's
that's yo listen that's my Fortnight guy
and I love the fact that y'all was
bothering him in the beginning because I
wouldn't never have reached out to him
and made you know a good friend and I
reached out to him because I didn't like
the bullying that he was receiving on
Twitter even though he can hold his own
that's so shady and then um me and I'm
started kicking it in the background
little by little little by little and
then you know we you know let it slip
that he let it slip though he's playing
fortnite I'm like yo I'm on it too and
um he's just been a great friend you
know playing fortnite with him so I just
want to give a shout out to uh so shady
that's my guy you know that's about it
sorry I just saw him pop up in there you
know
there you got Robert Kelly 2000 Super
Chat the static is Xbox telling y'all
not to snitch stuff we need snitch
then we got Simon Brady two pound Super
Chat King was it a low blow oh [__] got
lucky
um no it wasn't a low blow uh it was on
the Belt Line if you saw all the replays
that's why they're going to
um petition this fight to to get a
rematch I don't know how far that goes
because usig wants to fight Fury but
Fury has two fights running Gano that's
on paper and he's gonna make a boatload
of money so um I think usick
missed the boat they were supposed to be
fighting in September usick was holding
out and be honest with you I really
don't think usick wants to fight Fury I
wouldn't want to fight Fury if that guy
has so many question marks around him
he's 300 pounds yeah six seven six nine
with a long jab and a right hand and it
can move from round one to round 12. I
don't know how you do that and you're
not on something he has the best cycling
that I've ever seen in my life I do
believe that he's on stuff but that's
casting excursions because he beat my
guy at the same time I would not want to
fight that animal if he is not
completely clean because you can't beat
a guy with a good jab in the right hand
that can fight on the inside impossible
okay we got Eliot shlomovic member of a
39 months Lord bronze salute to the
Lord's much health and love to Lord Cog
and King is really adopting his bot
identity with the Optimus voice
the reason that happened is because you
guys told me to like unplug the zoom so
when I unplugged it I don't know why but
then King started sounding like that
like you know my wife was texting me
what's going on I wish I wish that I
knew what to do to auto correct that
because Keith was sounding pretty funny
with that it was hilarious imagine him
doing like like like a speech sound like
Optimus Prime it was ridiculous
listening Jamaican gym with an Optimus
Prime voice
it's a Jamaican gym with Optimus Prime
[Music]
podcasting keep at it guys yes yes
apologies apologies all right okay what
up baby what up Blaze good brother all
right now switch over to the current
stream we have n Bentley two five dollar
Super Chat apparently stream has issues
when you go without your hashtag beef
brother beef broth or beef broth
girls
oh my God
and we got Corey Tidwell 2010 attic just
drop kicked that NDA no it didn't yo
um dip down you're not getting Optimus
Prime and fortnite is over with bro
you're late you should have been playing
when I was playing it's over with now
it's done
then we got BT Maverick 707 10 super
chat R.I.P to the mri2 they tried to fit
beefy Cog into why it's never going to
walk the same with you no
[__] you set the standard that we all
should follow to the rest of the crew
htl shout out to you
that was that was kind of weird wow but
I I get it I get it it's a scenario
ah then we have let's play with each
other's joysticks here we go five
dollars Super Chat Starfield sea of
stars none of that matters Saab is the
only star that I want inside my black
hole
hey hey hey hey
back to you solved with these Super Chat
thank you thank you for your support
appreciate it
Brandy
to chat Forte is
PS currency at GameStop
are there more ps5s coming in than usual
oh man
let me stay quiet on this one yeah be
quiet yeah we ain't gonna talk about the
mountain the PlayStation 5S used I have
in my store in the background
all right then we got crack hooligan
gifted one IOP membership gifted as we
like to say gifted because we know how
Craig gets it done but thank you Craig
we appreciate it
then we got pods gaming mode for 27
months Lord bronze brother four days and
14 hours into get until I get my hands
on Starfield have a great show Lawrence
thank you brother appreciate you man
we're gonna have something it'll be
something
we'll talk about that soon
and we got JD gamer two dollars for chat
hey Forte to the rescue
let's say it to the coming in everything
got fixed then we got Corey Tidwell two
dollar Super Chat Spider-Man two better
let me swing the Jersey it ain't
happening oh well you might as well
figure something else out because
imaginary wall then we got fours oh God
imaginary walls there you go you got a
floor at least we got a floor pedal 2.0
puddle 2.0 then we got for the legend
two dollars we chat Phil double down on
Remnant two great game honestly yes yes
that Spider-Man thing is an artistic
change
it was a design choice design Choice
then we have let me see dreadpool five
dollar switch hack when I did shave back
a century ago I would look in the mirror
at a stranger looking back at me finally
I'm able to watch IOP live shout out to
you sir what's up dread man I mean um
breaking bread with Dread check that out
awesome and we got Blaze 4K 5 super chat
Sony is God and expect no less from
Blaze thank you brother appreciate it
even God can bleed
Yo God is dying we have forgotten your
God
oh yeah Corey did well five dollars
stupid chat addict not feeling the
parked that parked outside a school zone
look
what the hell
yeah
so we have a lot of roughness with the
two pound Super Chat has anyone seen or
heard from Sony no no he came up and
said hey take this and left
and we have hargit to me five Chinese
excuse me Hardy Johnny five dollar Super
Chat do you think Starfield will outsole
Spider-Man 2 currently Starfield is at
48 and Spider-Man at 61 on Amazon how is
it at GameStop
this man trying to get get me in trouble
um are you really not allowed to say
stuff like that
uh not until they actually come out oh
yeah okay yeah I mean but you know
everybody should know if you think about
it star feels available at Game Pass
PlayStation doesn't do anything like
that with Spider-Man so initially
Spider-Man is going to probably have
better pre-order numbers just because of
that I think starfield's gonna be the
higher selling volume of game just for
the fact that it's going to have a
longer tail just like Skyrim did
Spider-Man is like a one shoot thing
like over the course of one or two years
it's gonna probably hit its maximum
number Skyrim I mean starfield's gonna
sell for years to come
especially since it's on um PC day one
yeah
and those a lot of PC guys Game Pass be
damned they don't care that we're gonna
buy it right he's gonna buy the game no
matter what I love their mentality
baby then we got JD game for five
dollars for chat let me say it so the
Lords can save uh save it till Thursday
Starfield is everything we think it is
and more it is a generation it is
generationally transformative game of
the game of the year and game of the
generation yep yeah maybe that game is a
generation last generation
is always going to be the last of us too
because like I I really want to talk to
Neil druckman thank you
and read that too so I know you don't
want to talk about that either yeah
I'm not my mom
gold hit the like button for the iron
D.A dudes podcast shout out to you sir
it's amazing that our community can
literally turn anything into a joke yeah
it is that's the great part about it
then we have Cedric H gifted 10 IOP
memberships let's put the crest into
chat for Cedric H thank you I appreciate
that
then we have queen queen Beezy two
dollar Super Chat I'm making a beef pot
roast today in honor of cogs
shout out to you Queen
there we have let me see this is it and
that was the first Super Chat from Queen
Beezy thank you appreciate that that's
what's up then we have Homeless Bird
five dollar Super Chat
love to the Lords and all the denizens
of the realm PSA save often currently
replaying several hours of P5 Persona 5
Royal and it's not ideal hmm
that is definitely a thing I would I
would advise that for any game slash RPG
especially stuff that's happening soon
yeah yeah
there we have Necromancer sale gifted
five IOP memberships thank you bro
appreciate that man
and we got crack hole again once again
remember for 12 months Lord bronze how
many days since the Lord's turned their
psbr2 on
um I'm the only one on that has one
um unless Forte has what do you have one
I can't even dignify that with a
response
um it's funny we're not for the the
Starfield Early Access I would have
played some on my vacation and I have
not so it's been quite some time and
it's dusty it's unfair though because
there's some some games that came out
that are good I just have not
but it was
how many layers of dust is on it I'll
wait for the thing to be uh 200.
oh yeah that is well worth it
and then I'll be right here no but to be
fair like they don't I mean they really
have not done anything to make the Sony
guy really want to come I'll go out and
buy that they just haven't like just
haven't you know support
I'm the agnostic dude to support it and
I'm just like all the Xbox dude
supported it I just can't see myself
buying something that costs more than
the console I bought yeah yeah got at
least be less like if it was like 400
I'd be like oh okay yeah yeah not five
hundred dollars yeah I'm down for that
it was the price of the fake handheld
yeah I'm inside
then we have Michael Mooney with the
five pound Super Chat what is the
console pallet amounts per current
console
I guess that's a forte question I don't
know if you can answer that
yeah we got Nintendo Super Chat the game
of last Jen was breath of the wild no
other answer okay I mean that could be
it was mine I doubt it though
uh then we have parasite 82 green with
the five pound Super Chat uh duboiselle
Dubois felt robbed last night like uh
when lying crying wrong wrongly advising
Jim Ryan watch the Final Fantasy 14
coming to Xbox announcement
yo you ain't lying brother tell the
truth ain't the devil
all right and we are done we're caught
up thank you oh right so let's get to
our first topic uh the power of the
series that's is it in question and you
know we can go back to the first article
this is brought to you by gamersrand
msn.com and true achievements Laramie
Studio CEO swing Vic uh believes that
the Xbox series s is not holding back
the current generation the consoles
despite the lower specs compared to the
series X Vic argues that the difference
between the specs of the series s and
the series X has been exaggerated in the
series s simply requires development
efforts from studios in June Vic
realized revealed that the Microsoft
Engineers are assisting with Boulder's
Gate 3 which might require some
compromises on the Xbox as the team has
some difficulty getting split screen to
work with the series s Vic also now said
that that's that it's not the Xbox
series X that's holding back the
development it takes development effort
so with that being said we knew that
they were going to uh hold that console
version for the series uh for series
systems until next year
well Phil did an interview with IGN and
um he with Destin and during Gamescom
and he announced that uh that they were
helping them out to get the game to the
consoles well iron came out and said
that the console versions will be coming
out this year
minus the series s having split screen
which will be announced at a later date
Microsoft doubled down on their tweet
talking about that they will help to get
that uh split screen up and running
my question to the realm is is this
pertinent news and is the series that's
holding back this current gen is the
lack of power I would like to go to
Forte first and give your thoughts on
this subject matter all right so is this
worthy news the only worthy news about
this is the fact that Xbox has come to
the sense that they feel like they need
to
separate themselves when it comes to
their parody Clause when it comes to
feature parody on games right that's the
only thing that's really notable of that
conversation because you know the people
that spent the spent 500 on their
console shouldn't be held back for a
feature that's not available on another
one you know especially when it's a very
small sample size of people that
actually take advantage of that feature
not saying those people aren't important
because they are but ain't nobody really
looking for it like that so I think that
was like the biggest thing that I took
from just that part of it I've never I
never thought this series S held back
development of games I did I did think
it made it probably a little bit more
intensive for them to be able to focus
in and actually say oh paint by numbers
and this is going to be easy you know
when you got three of the four consoles
pretty much around the same spec you
know Xbox series X a little more a
little bit more powerful than PS4 drive
and you do have an outlier in the S
being a little bit not a little bit you
know quite a bit less powerful it still
it still has the same C uh CPU the GPU
is the thing that's getting we got a
memory issue but that's the same thing
to deal with on PC every day and deal
with that every time you you make a game
for PC
you're dealing with not you're dealing
with hundreds of different you know
specks of console of PCS and stuff so
it's definitely going to take more
effort the S is definitely not holding
back anything I just think it just
really showcases how developers want
things to be as easy as possible so they
can get their games out as fast as
possible and I can't be mad at them
about that but the biggest thing is as
long as we're in the in a world where
the only difference between snx games is
resolution and frame rate and the
feature part of it is basically just say
okay you know what you're buying into by
buying a cheaper spec system you're not
going to get all the bells and whistles
that the Next Generation Xbox series X
is going to have then I think that's
going to be the best thing this is all
blown out of quick portion because it
was kind of promised in a statement that
these systems were going to kind of be
the same and that kind of happened not
to be the thing so uh it's kind of an
a nothing burger at this point but I do
like the fact that Xbox decided to do
this they're showing that they're
willing to adapt they're showing that
they're willing to change their stance
on stuff like that and it takes games
like a bonus Gate 3 being at a 96 97
metacreated Game of the Year Contender
not being on your platform for that year
that definitely does sway the opinion to
say hey we got to get this game on our
console what do we need to do it well
let's make let's make some concessions
to do that and that's what they did and
I feel like that's going to be something
they're going to do in the future once
you do it once you really don't have a
problem doing it again
all right uh Lord Sovereign your
thoughts
yeah I mean I I grew Forte 100 like the
thing about the only thing that the that
the series sort of brings different to
the table is that it is one more skew
that they have to worry about right and
then when you think about the console
space it's really something that we
haven't seen in the console space when
you have a you know we have multiple
skus to worry about on the same platform
right so that that is just something
that again
devs have been dealing with this forever
forever on the PC side and if they start
you start making PC games that obviously
are on the console as well that is
something that that you're going to have
to deal with so it's it's just what it
is it's more work it's more optimization
it takes more time and so I can see
somebody whatever getting frustrated
being like yes the series that's his
fault whatever because we have to also
focus on this but the truth of the
matter is just what it's it's a matter
of time and and resources to optimize
and get it on there
um and that that's pretty much it like
it isn't that it's specifically gimping
and the ability to do certain things or
whatever like because you go into it
already knowing and I think it was great
that Phil sort of pointed this out you
go into it knowing you're spending half
the money almost essentially to get a
console that is still considered a Next
Generation console you cannot expect it
to perform the same as a series X you
just can't like if if it did if it did
then right some Microsoft is doing
something very right on the dev side and
very wrong on the marketing side right
so definitely so it is one of those
things like it's it's a dumb argument
because at the end of the day you know
what you're getting it nobody argues
when it says oh I can't do ray tracing
or it can't do 4K they told you from the
jump to that console is a 1080p slash
1440p and that 1440p is a very uh it's a
1080p console fine right but you get the
bells and whistles of what the X can do
with a lot of the other stuff in terms
of oh mostly frame rate right and even
then they still haven't utilized it
fully we talked about how the fact that
a lot of that secret sauce has been
talked about from the beginning of the
generation for both s and X isn't really
there like it's not really there and
hopefully with fsr3 we start to see it
more because it's like it's like come on
you have these things you talked about
that's built into the metal of these
systems let's utilize it so they can
punch above their weight
um I remember having Jason Ronald down
we talked about how this was the first
time I felt that the secret sauce that
was being talked about wasn't Pie in the
Sky it was like real and you can see it
and you could see it on the PC side
where I was like yo wait a minute it
really works yeah yeah because it was
one of those things where they said it
and they said it it works for both PC
and console and seeing it work on the PC
side I'm like okay this is viable right
this is not es RAM and and the cloud
working together
Master process right is going to work so
it's been disappointing that stuff has
been slow to sort of come to fruition
and and show end games there have been
some games that have utilized it like I
remember there was talk around scorn and
stuff like that but again you want to
see it in the most popular games you
want to see it in the game that
everybody's going to want to play it
right so um so yeah to me that that is
that um
the series us we'll and again there'll
be more discussions about what the
series does can do
um later in the week but um
it is one of those things where it's
like it's it's a non-starter I think it
was it was smart on Microsoft's part to
do it I don't know what they do it again
right because it just the pushback
they've gotten I don't know if they do
it again maybe with next gen they do
what Sony did and give you two skews one
with a disk drive and without and that's
how they differentiate I don't know that
they do it again because there's been a
lot of pushback there's a lot of Hassle
and a lot of you know we don't know but
they're gonna do what's best for them
and the numbers May tell the tale at the
end of the day if this is a money game
and a numbers game yeah then yeah I
could see it happening again
um so hey whatever works for them but
again I it's a non-starter I'm glad that
they sat down it was always weird to me
that the parody thing was a thing simply
because like we just said the console is
not as capable as an ex so when you talk
about feature parity especially you know
you gotta you gotta you got to think
about the fact that the feet the
features also include stuff that is
dependent on the power of the console
right right and something like some the
you know
couch Co-op and stuff like that is
something that the ex could probably do
considerably better than yes so
did say that it really wasn't the
console itself that it was more that it
needed development time
anymore a time and maybe a little bit of
a nudge you know
in the right direction the right
direction okay I'm just saying to make
it happen quickly right and I I think
Phil realized to like Forte's Point like
this is a game that came out and kind of
took over the Zeitgeist we're talking
very high Metacritic scores so now it's
in the eye everybody's sort of watching
out for it so for Xbox to miss out on
that Zeitgeist and and be completely out
of the year uh without you know Ballers
gate three I think it was the right move
on first part to try try to get that
moving as quickly as possible and still
have it within this calendar year where
it can almost count as a second launch
on for the for the game on Xbox consoles
right
um so I I'm excited to see when it comes
to Xbox because again I think I think
the thing that really really helped with
that conversation too is the fact that
larion never came out and dogged the ass
yeah it never came out and said that
we're having they never even said that
they had an issue with the S they just
said okay get split screen working
um and we had to delay the game they
never talked about the power of the
system they never talked about any
miscomes or shortcomings that the
console had so of both of these
developers what they do come out they
instantly go to the lower common
denominator to say the S is holding this
back Laria never did that so it's easier
for Phil Spencer to go and we all it
feels a very level-headed person just
listening and talking just hearing from
them and stuff
he probably went into this like hey I'm
gonna help this studio out as much as I
can because they didn't throw us under
the bus like most other developers did
so it kind of probably gave him a little
bit extra uh incentive to go in and say
hey let's make this happen for this
studio not only because they have a
really really good game on their hands
that we don't want to miss out on but
they've been super respectful during
this whole process when it comes to that
and I think a lot of people don't think
of stuff like that when it comes to
these these uh negotiations behind the
scenes I think it's you know it's great
business practice but let me get loaded
in on this because this is your topic
addict oh and I wanted to you round this
out what did you think about this being
that you brought this to the realm talk
to me
you mute it
my bad I think when it comes to this
that there's there's clearly some
limitations on the series S I don't
necessarily think it's a if the machine
can't do it it's how long it's going to
take to do it right and you know that
might delay certain things and you know
even though Xbox is willing to put that
kind of research and development and you
know extend
development Cycles a few months to get
games working properly on the series
that's that doesn't mean that you know
third party or even you know smaller Dev
teams are going to be able to afford to
do that you got AAA people uh you know
the Publishers like we don't care like
we we we'll just drop it I think you
you've seen that uh throughout the time
look we've heard from multiple dads that
you know that this this can be done it's
just how long it's going to take and
unfortunately some developers and
Publishers that they're not going to
wait that that amount of time true
all right so I'll just finish up the
topic
uh it's kind of like what I said
Phil comes around Hey listen uh can we
get this going
you know because uh you do want this
title and if you if you are your console
your brand is known as the king of the
RPGs and you can't have this RPG out
there without adding it to Your Arsenal
for the year you want to stay in between
that Zeitgeist uh I knew it wasn't
coming out in September I'm pretty sure
it was just a strategic move on larion's
part to make sure that they've missed
star field on the Xbox platform because
you know being launched in Game Pass I
don't think that you can compete uh the
anticipation for the Xbox fan base I
don't think that you can compete with
that so you know launching on Sony they
don't have anything in September put it
on PC PC dudes is going to gravitate
towards anyway uh all of us people I was
listen I was gonna buy a stadia
for the game to be honest with you and I
was going to keep that 100. that's as
soon as the game come out I was gonna
get it so you're gonna get you're going
to get the people that want the game to
get the game
the Xbox gamer seemed at that point in
time to be left out Phil turn around
double deck double back listen what we
need to get this done apparently Money
Talks BS walks all right and I said that
before
I told people that I didn't believe a
lot of things that certain people say
and listen I'm a skeptic by heart right
and you have to prove to me well they
proved to me that was BS because a week
ago it was next year and now it's this
year right but they also dropping uh the
split screen because if the split screen
is giving you some hassle we don't know
to what level the split screen is given
hassle we don't know if it's making it
crash we don't know if it's slowing it
down we don't know anything but the
assumption is that it doesn't work right
and that's pretty much the narrative
from a certain fan base oh you can't get
it to work on your box yeah it's okay
you can't get rdna2 on your box but
we're gonna talk about something
different our DNA tubes coming out next
week you won't have any of it uh but one
thing to be on the Xbox One to do it one
thing I just want to be fair on yeah is
we have seen this be like a thing like
they abandoned split screen and the
forza franchise it's the first time
they've ever done that like I do feel
like there is a common denominator here
and if the comedy denominator is little
man let it be known but is the common
denominator little man or is it the fact
that we as technologically advanced
medium
don't use split screen anymore and if
the metrics is so far low do you even
put development time in a feature that
is not being utilized by the majority of
the fan base you know back in the days
when everybody was sitting next to each
other playing Mario Kart yeah that was
something totally different the metrics
to that spoke to that so you had to
fundamentally start from when you're
developing this has to be in part of
parsley literally they built the
consoles with four four controller
boards right yeah right so it this is
the this is a huge problem when it gets
to this space do we actually need some
of the old stuff that we were used to
having in the Box just for the sake of
checking off a box I don't know when the
last time I used split screen in
anything all the guys that I do play I
play with my friends online right and
half the time I'm sitting in my house in
my boxes there's nobody next to me and
if my wife is sitting next to me she
damn sure don't have a control in the
hand she's just looking at me and saying
I don't even know how you do this all
day long but
that's where we are now
so is it something that we're holding on
to like a lot of us hold on to the
physical copy I had one guy that was
inside my DM and he said you know he's
having a problem with GameStop and he
they told him that he wouldn't get his
physical copy of Starfield until the six
and I was like that's crazy right he
said what should I do I said you have
Game Pass yes he said yes because he got
the collector's edition of the Starfield
and he wants to steal case he wants it I
said well played inside Game Pass
and then when it comes to your house you
have it it's a win-win situation so I
said this kind of avoids that problem
but let's say he just only wanted
physical you know we're at a point now
where it really doesn't matter
if we're holding on to Old tropes he's
an old Trope holder right me it didn't
bother me I said I have the digital I
don't ever care to see a stockpile in
the corner anymore that was more of um a
measuring stick your friends come over
look at all the games I got how many
friends are coming over my house for me
to say look at the games I got I see
people online taking pictures of Stacks
and stacks of old games I just see
stores I'll be your friend King
you know but now when we when people
show you the games and they take a
screen all the games in a digital
library the digital library is a
currency now what I'm just saying is are
we blowing it out of proportion
with something that is a relic to the
community and should we even care so I
mean I heard from you guys and you know
Forte you hit it out the park uh
Sovereign you know um addict same thing
I I think it's really a nothing burger
and for those people that do need it
please I would love to see your metrics
and be honest with you if you have a
series s and you're you're really
concerned about this please let me know
how much you play split screen I maybe
you had an idea that you was going to
play with your kids or whatever I don't
know but again they're going to work on
it Microsoft came out and doubled down
and said that you know they're going to
work really hard to get that out and I
think that is really larion Studios uh
biggest thing but let's get to these
super chats so we can get to the next
topic because we're Balling on all
cylinders we're moving and we're
grooving let's do this song sure give me
one second
roll back a little bit uh
rabbit salvation
uh let me see uh two dollars which had
The Witcher 3 was Game of the generation
shout out to Rapid salvation then we
have X XD Melo seven five dollar switch
hack a vegan episode with no beef in
sight thank you for always saving my
labor Sundays long live the king and the
crew yeah King and them other guys
it's here to provide
you then we got Robert Kelly two dollar
Super Chat and Mortals runs at 490p on
Series S lacking beef
from what I hear Immortals is kind of a
technical sort of Beast so it is it's
out of control oh it's it's ridiculous
it's crazy I think I think digital
Foundry broke it down it's like yeah
this is pushing consoles period yeah
it's the Unreal Engine five bro I don't
care what anybody say I believe that
they didn't really take in account how
much of uh uh um a hog that engine is
with all the fluff and I think by the
time we get to the next consoles they
would have mitigated a lot of that fluff
and bloat inside that uh that engine I
think a little bit again we're going
back to the pandemic in covet like I
think the implementation of ue5 got
delayed somewhat right yes it's kind of
late we're coming into what the third
year third three and a half years of
these console cycles and very little in
the way of ue5 sort of and it's like
we're on the first year exactly exactly
so let me see that we have JD gamer 10
super chat question to the panel what do
you think the secret sauce is going to
do for the Xbox series Xs and and buy
and by that I mean the ml on-chip
machine learning that isn't on the PS5
what will uh AI be able to do well
that's the thing it's all theoretical we
don't know what it'll be able to do
because there's been nothing to utilize
it so we don't know I mean we I think we
talked about this a long time ago yeah
Jason Ronald Don is like the hope and
the expectation was
AI that feels more realistic right
that's more reactive to your actions and
things like that
um in terms of generally what we expect
out of a next-gen console will probably
be like denser worlds that feel more
alive you know in a GTA game being able
to go into more building stuff like that
um but again it's a matter of when we're
going to see it but that's kind of what
we think we're hoping I mean for the
fact that Microsoft is leading the
industry along with Elon Musk
um with AI and you felt you know with
them purchasing chat GT and all this
other stuff that they would be able to
streamline some of this uh Tech right
right and and have it work inside the
box I don't I'm not a developer so I
don't know what the development tools
look like how robust uh some of these
things are or are they online you know
when it comes to your development but I
think the games that we're getting now
were started a long time ago and I think
the game's coming from the future on
because there's one game in particular
I'm super excited to see on Tuesday that
we can't talk about yet uh we'll talk
about later but that game from
everything that I heard is using all
that Tech that they talked about so I
want to see it I better see it and if I
don't see it then I'll then I'm gonna
die with spiral but if I do it see it
then you know I'm an upwards buyer
then we have look roughness five pound
Super Chat like all little man owners I
expect to lose out on some features now
bd3 is a great graphics turn based RPG
give me the game I don't need Co-op
that's what's up Ruffner yeah I'm sure a
lot of people feel the same way we got
hargit chani member for 26 months Lord
gold just pointing out switches two skus
in the same system docked and undocked
pretty sure there were differences
between PS4 and PS4 Pro and the one
versus One X should bg3 launch in Game
Pass I think it should those are all
valid points that they are those are
technically two skus but when you think
about it it's a little different because
they asked from the start of the
generation hey there's going to be two
skews and the difference is if you think
about the different differences between
these consoles that you point out and
the series S as opposed to the X the
differences are a little more pronounced
right it the the differences in Ram and
things of that nature the Pro versus the
PS4 versus the PS4 the thing about that
was that they were never going to
develop exclusively for the pro right
right the pro was an afterthought now
when you're talking about the series s
and the X coming out day and date
together that's a different
consideration altogether I'm going to
tell you right now most people didn't
care about
developing for the pro unless it was
Sony first party and not even them
really right
um same thing with the switch the switch
no nobody's really thinking about the
little bit of extra power that that
you're going to get from a switch docked
so it's different because the
considerations are more pronounced I
think you don't get no power from the
switch dot yeah you know unfortunately
you don't and it looks like the switch
light is the same machine it's just in a
cheaper place it plays five less games
that the regular switch plays yeah
PlayStation DV came out it talked about
the reason they made a pro and it wasn't
before it wasn't really for uh even
though they put 4K gaming on the box
which marketing uh 101 it was mostly
because of VR VR was the main reason
they did that they said that it helped
with that more than anything else and
then the one the one X the 1X was a GPU
bump you had the same CPU so the game
was running the same you had 4K
capability for sure but beyond that at
the core unless they were all games and
bad compat they really weren't doing
much in terms of performance with the 1X
so it was all about the marketing if you
look at it that's it it's marketing I
can push back against that those games
that were initially using the 1X power
you could say the forza
um the Assassin's Creed uh Origins and
the Crackdown those those three games
that they showed us when we was at The
Fan Fest and I got a chance to talk with
the devs in the background they actually
utilized the X they actually utilize
yeah yeah 4K so that was the first time
that Microsoft decided that we're going
to take the power narrative back so
the PlayStation 4 Pro in my opinion was
net necessary for the VR but it also
gave it a boost when it came to other
games so it was necessary and I think
the pro versions of consoles are
necessary for elitists like ourselves
who want to play a game on on Console at
a higher Fidelity but do they actually
uh develop force of a specific skill I
don't believe they do I believe that
it's more of it takes advantage of the
overhead the machine it does and it
knows when you put the game in that it's
going to run at the highest Fidelity and
you know nobody cared before when you
had a PlayStation Pro and there were
certain
um resolutions that was afforded to you
opposed to the the lower skill console
and this is the same thing with the
series s you know there's certain things
that will be afforded to you playing on
the higher console and we should just
come to acknowledge that and know that
to be a fact and don't cry and moan if
you do want certain obstacles to be
removed then you do have the ability to
take that console go trade it in and go
get the series X console and therefore
removes that barrier that you feel that
is there invisibly to you so if you want
that Co-op just go down and take that
little man that because you was cheaping
out in the beginning and you brought
little man now you're trying to figure
out how you're gonna get steak and
potatoes with it no you get the steak
you're just not getting the potatoes you
want the potatoes go trade that potato
in and go get in the series there you go
then we have JD gamer five dollar Super
Chat what's Microsoft buys larion
Studios square and Sega then they will
be the RPG Masters
I need you to come to my job one day
next week JD's and we could talk about
your slander and stuff
always objective takes
he does this right in front of me well
he literally talked to customers at my
store and be like yeah this that the
other I was like you crazy don't buy
this
yeah we got JD give her again five
dollar Super Chat incoming ad Xbox is
the only place to play the biggest RPGs
in the world bg3 and Starfield only
available on the Xbox all launching in
2023 play with us yeah this is Aaron
Greenberg there you go yeah yeah slogan
right there I think Microsoft knows this
bro
and then we got Gamers play HUD x0
member for 33 months Lord bronze what up
Lords it seems like a lot of Fanboys or
gotcha boys are all over and trying to
get people to call out Bethesda and stop
the hype Hold the Line
bro it's you The Knockout blow is
imminent bro when I'm telling you to
knock off blows coming it's coming
then we got zip Davis five dollar Super
Chat only a week left until Starfield
slumps big link we going we going in
Peter Moore style taking all these punks
head on
I do think that
this year's game of the year
is going to come between Starfield Zelda
and Baldur's Gate like I don't think
look I love Spider-Man and I think
Spider-Man is going to be a fantastic
experience but for some reason part of
me doesn't think that's in the game do
you yo I'm so upset that this is the
second time my Spider-Man will hit the
streets and he not gonna get game of the
year and it's gonna be Game of the Year
for me I don't care what really happens
to be honest with you I'm a listen I'm a
spidey head so I don't care who wins I
know I'm gonna pick Spider-Man be glad
I'm not voting
there we go let me see uh change channel
Israel with the five dollar Super Chat
Canadian dollars let us all please have
a moment of silence for all the parents
who buy a PS portal for their kids but
don't own a PlayStation
[Applause]
we're gonna need some educated store
associates to really parse this stuff
out for real then we have a crumble
Grumble five dollars do for chat if XBox
was lead platform with series SP as big
of an issue Xbox will be lead platform
by the end of this gen beginning of next
gen in my opinion yeah
and we have parasite 82 green with the
five pound Super Chat gaming Forte's
background keeps making me think of Def
Jam icon on 360. that game was the was
the bomb okay I'm trying to see this and
fight for New York was fired too yes
back there I didn't like icon I I liked
what they were kind of doing the concept
but fight for New York was oh my God
life in New York was what's up
then we got Halo reach around two
dollars
how to get in trouble smooth attic got
my Hardware overheating like a PS4
I think that
deserves a thigh slab addict I really do
yeah you're looking for your thighs baby
too too busy and uh producer mode then
we have Chris R5 super Jack King makes a
good point on digital games but it
depends on the company Xbox carries over
your library while Nintendo will make
you buy it all again yeah hopefully
hopefully with this new Nintendo online
thing it'll be in the service and they
realize that they can milk you that way
but we'll see we'll see I don't think so
I think Nintendo needs their hand
smacked to the point of doing this don't
ever forget Microsoft was I mean even
though they are the leaders in the
market in game uh Revival and
um keeping them safe but um
what do we call that uh sorry when you
was calling it before yes
yeah and I think Microsoft leads the
charge but do they lead the charge only
because they're in last place I mean I
don't no right but is it a factor that
could be considered I believe so they
got if they figured out a way to do it
at a time when they needed to get back
into good graces of people so if they
were if they were the market leader at
the time and they figured out back
compact would they have tried to
monetize it who knows like you don't
know right yeah you never know but uh
yeah Nintendo is definitely monetize it
that's for sure
then we got Chris R5 oh we read that
already thank you Chris R then we got
Lord of Raffles two pound Super Chat
Co-op is a 20 year old Relic a niche and
now an excuse imagine true there's no
need not Co-op couch Co-op right yeah
couch Co-op
then we have boss red 77 two dollar
Super Chat man I got two Xbox series s's
what do I need split screen for yeah
that's right go over there and play over
there and then you go somebody on one TV
like we used to do in the old days
get out of my room stop watching my
screen yeah that's watching my screen
stop cheesing me man stop teasing me bro
then we got slobo back slap remember for
38 buzzlord bronze the first descendant
is greater than Destiny by the way I
hope Forte isn't managing the stream
you got it right we got it right now
then let's put the crust in the chat for
Lord bronze the angry therapist MD shout
out to you sir thank you oh I like that
Doctor Doom yeah yeah
then we have Marvin ginyard two dollars
to be chat let's save the Appalachian
platypus
in fact I thought we were saving the
endangered Series S but that's for sure
then we got boys a legend two dollars
for chat gears four and five look
outstanding on the Xbox One X they do
they absolutely do rage uh what was uh
HDR right HDR 4K but again performance
is largely uneffective because the
Jaguar cars are just not what now
uh let me see that we have Sasquatch in
time two dollar stupid Sasquatches lots
of a chat take split screen but give
disk Read Drive add-on uh yeah I I think
they might do that same thing too you
know I think Sony will is coming out
with that at some point right and I
think it's smart give people the choice
then we have Nintendo Taco chat uh let
me see uh Starfield won't get a 96 meta
or sell 20 million in one month
it was he's comparing it to Zelda of
course oh okay whatever I mean what
other games are going to do what Zelda
did yeah that's not too many well it can
have that but it ain't gonna get game of
the year so you can keep that there but
I can tell you that right now
then we have chaosanti twenty dollars
for the chat Starfield isn't isn't using
all features to my understanding since
it started third party while some
optimization can be done but some like
mesh shaders which offsets Ram limits on
the S can't be patched in later salute
the ILP yeah there's just certain things
that if the game wasn't built from the
ground up within the Microsoft ecosystem
yeah it's probably stuff unless they
decide to go back and start from scratch
which they did not do yeah it's certain
things are just not going to have right
um but again
I want to see what the models are going
to do when the modders get a hold of it
exactly yeah yeah for sure
um okay we're caught up next all right
that's what's up so we're going on to
the next topic the next topic is my
topic which is really funny and um this
topic is brought to you by CNET uh Story
by uh Scott Stein uh Sony's Playstation
Portable portal for the PlayStation 5.
what we know so far so Sony came out and
uh gave out a list of things uh
it just it was it was pretty extensive
the stuff that we did get a chance to
see we got a chance to see the elite
headset we got a chance to see some
earbuds uh the PlayStation link and we
also got a chance to see the name of the
the cue light or the Q whatever it was
uh the code name it's now named
PlayStation portal Sony is making a
return to gaming handhelds in a sense
the PlayStation Vita is the last gaming
handheld is long gone but earlier this
year sonian announced a surprise new
device project Q it looked very much
like a giant display fused with a dual
sense controller from a PlayStation 5.
that handheld became the PlayStation
Portable at PlayStation portal at 200
and some tax gaming device coming at the
end of this year CNET has already gotten
a chance to play with it Sony has also
detailed more information on its own
site the handheld which should play all
PlayStation 5 games over Wi-Fi has a
eight inch HD LCD screen and a
controller that has all the features of
the Dual sense that's standard on the
Playstation 5. download 6 are a bit
smaller but the layout is otherwise
absolutely the same streaming handhelds
uh defined or a Define now trend
with the Android devices like logitech's
gcloud and the razer's edge the plate
the PC gaming related devices like the
steam deck and aux rally Ally I love my
Ally but the portable is specifically
made as the second screen and a local
play option for the PlayStation 5. not
as a cloud streaming or Standalone
device Alternatives also exists the
backbone one for your gaming controller
that also fits your phone now that we
got all the information and we heard
about the limitations as far as no
Bluetooth in the Box
um
what else uh that it only works with the
the earbuds and it doesn't work with the
headset even though they both have link
uh it's an attractive looking device but
I want to ask you guys and I want to
bring it to the realm and I'm going to
start off with a lord attic first uh
what do you believe is the relevance of
this machine being released and do you
believe that uh it accentuates your
existing Hardware that you do have with
the PlayStation 5. oh one second uh let
me give a shout out to the
1023 watching now if this is your first
time uh joining around please like
follow And subscribe hit the
notification button and no I'm not the
normal host Lord beefy is not here he's
being released from the hospital and too
much he's he's really pause but uh
please give uh well wishes out to Laura
Cognito is uh our natural host he will
be back in this seat uh following next
week when we come back from Pax but this
is iron Lords podcast and thank you for
showing up please hit that like button
uh Lord attic please let me know your
thoughts on the PlayStation reveal you
say of the whole Suite of stuff and um
largely around the PlayStation portal
I don't watch um
I don't know what sports this individual
is in well what's that mean where he's
like we don't care
it's like look like I got a steam deck I
got a switch
if I'm the I guess this is gonna work
out for certain things but to me the
indie games that I would play
I could just play on the steam deck
right right I don't see myself playing
like God of War on this
I don't see myself playing
whatever the next Last of Us for the
most part I'm going to want to sit down
and actually play something
I don't see the I don't see the market
for this like if you could take this out
and about I could see the market for it
but I just don't personally see people
sitting on their couch
playing this on the tab now now Kofi
shout out to Kofi he brought up a good
point if this could be integrated into
their games to be kind of like a Wii U
pad
where you know the inventories in the
middle and they use it as like a
controller too I can see that working
better but as just like walking around
you know I guess you know if I'm if I'm
fighting a valkyrie and God of War and I
gotta go to use the bathroom I guess I
can play this on the throne
it's just to me in my personal
I don't see the use for me now obviously
there's a lot of scenarios where you
know you you got kids you're fighting
over the TVs I got three TVs on to worry
about that I got I got my computer set
up I got plenty of places to play this
so I particularly don't have to worry
about that I can see a market in some
way shape or form but once again is an
ally or a steam deck more of an approach
than this that's that's my question and
and at the end of the day it's like you
know I could see some people using it
but just to me this thing's in the
bushes
that's that's a good price you know I
think it's cheaper
I think it's cheaper than the I think
you lost a bet because of this didn't oh
well it wasn't a bet it was well sort of
it was it was a Time Time Warren or Tom
Henderson
um right uh yeah so Tom Henderson told
me I told I thought it would be 300 if
it came out and it wasn't a bend the
knee it was more or less he said that
I'll buy one for you if if it's 300 he
kind of knew the price that they was
working with I thought that uh and when
I get to the part I will elaborate a
little bit more I thought that it would
be certain other Tech that should be
that is normalized in the marketplace at
this point in time in the box and that
Tech isn't there so of course uh if
something costs you twelve dollars to
make uh you can actually get it out the
door for 200 so I was under Assumption
of other things but uh shout out to you
definitely Tom you definitely got that
and you know um remember you lost your
eyebrows so uh you know your eyebrows so
I get I guess to me you you know if you
like this cool but
it's just not gonna do nothing for me
you know if I want to play the majority
see the thing is that I would only play
games that make sense on the move right
like that it can't play on the switch
they got their first party stuff the
only games that make sense for me to
play is games that you know a lot of
Indie Games I would play like sea of
stars on it right I guess I could make
that but at that point now I'm not a
primary PlayStation user okay so if I if
I cared more about trophies I don't even
really care about achievements these
days but if I can get achievements or
trophies I prefer achievements over
trophies because I have more
achievements and you know it goes on to
a bigger goal so I can understand maybe
a trophy you know an actual PlayStation
fan might want this more than me but
since trophies isn't a factor to me I'd
rather play the steam version on on the
steam that I feel that and okay so Forte
I'm I'm intrigued to hear your opinion
about it being that you're in the retail
aspect of it and you know um I'm pretty
sure that once this was announced the
the pre-orders went live
what have you been seeing from your
aspect of it because you have a unique
aspect that none of us uh on this panel
share
oh man so
pre-owners have not gone live yet
because PlayStation doesn't know when
what they're going to do with we don't
know if they're going to make it
exclusive to the PlayStation Store like
they did with most of their Hardware
first so they haven't really given any
information on that yet
for people have asked about it but the
biggest thing
I worry about is the People Are People
buying what they think they're getting
because a lot of people see PlayStation
portal
and they see a handheld do they know
that this thing is Wi-Fi do they know
that you can only stream to it
is that a that information yes is out
there but we already know most of the
buying you know consumers don't aren't
as educated on this type of stuff as us
right so it's kind of relied upon us as
the associates or the people that sell
it to them to let them know like hey
do you have do you know what this does
you know it was just like when a person
would buy a connect game it was like hey
do you have a connect because people
just see a game they'd be like oh this
looks cool well do you have the thing
that this could be worth it's gonna be
used on
for myself
I can't do it first of all I feel like
it's a disrespect to the word PSP
because I feel like the PSP is one of
the best handhelds that was ever made
and I just felt like they should have
came with a different name for it like a
different acronym or something because I
it just it just doesn't sit right with
me for it to be that Forte imagine being
a PSP be the two guy that wants this
platform to come back wants his handheld
to be rejuvenated and not only do they
make you something you didn't ask for
but they give it to PSP and they give
they give it the name of the of the one
great not one great handheld they had a
couple of them but I like the Vita yeah
I like the video Vita was cool I just
think for the most part
I think because the Nintendo like people
look at well people do it on a switch
right but the switch was from day one
conceived to do exactly what it's doing
right now exactly the system that this
is a this is an add-on feature to A
system that is predominantly your not
even predominantly it's only uses for
when you're at home
and you use it when you're at home so
get yes is it cool to give people the
extra incentive to like say like Lord
addict said you can go to the throne and
you can play God of War Ragnarok on it I
think most people just pause the game it
just go to the bathroom exactly right
like for you know a lot of people you
know the higher you get up age takes a
little bit longer you're gonna be in
there a little longer so you know I
gotta focus and concentrate but so I
don't want to deal with Prada you know
figure out my inventory management when
I'm doing something like that so I think
yes
it's some people are gonna buy it
they're going to buy it just because
like people like Tech and stuff uh
people like to be on The Cutting Edge
and things like that if they ever did
like little updates that did make it
like a controller like you see exactly
what Kobe's talking about where it's
aboard an extension of the game that
you're playing and you can use it in
other aspects then I can see the value
being there but I just don't see
a place for the consumer with this
product that right you only are tied to
the house it's like you it's like you're
stuck in the house like people say yeah
you can be on Wi-Fi like at Starbucks or
something as long as your PlayStation
know you can still get access to it but
I'm sitting there like that internet
ain't the greatest either it's like you
ain't gonna never get better internet
than the internet in your own house so
if you ain't gonna use it in your own
four walls
what is this good for and if I want to
play a game that's intensive like that
where I care enough I'm just gonna play
it on my TV that that's my big things
like who is this for like really like
who is this for it's obviously for
somebody because you know this has
gotten really crazy
I'm gonna put in uh the poll would you
buy this I don't would you buy the saw
b-roll would you use this stuff
buys everything
let me let me set solve up
you The Tech Guy you saw the text and
the specs and everything come out for
this machine
what was your thoughts
prior and then you know uh
what you had anticipated something going
in like yo what was your thought process
going in then what was your thought
process after it got revealed because
going in I'm pretty sure that you had a
different idea of what it should be and
what Sony Excellence is and what you
actually are getting what's your thought
process going in before in your thought
process after the fact
well I think before my thought process
was
um it was going to be expensive right
like it was going to be more expensive
than they made it um usually Sony does
not again you look at the psvr2 you look
at the Dual sense Edge and I'm gonna
make an comparison there
um these These are expensive peripherals
they don't really care about price point
in that regard they're confident that
you know that their base is going to buy
it obviously psvr 2 is a different thing
I think they knew that was going to be a
tech sink and you know the super super
hardness of the hardcore are going to
buy it and then and that's it
um
with this so when they finally announced
the price the full name and what it
could do I think we knew going in
already there was going to be just a
remote play thing right and I right for
me what bothered me about that is like
there's so many now it's by especially
now in this market where you have you
have Remote Play to everything right
over cloud or over direct remote play
over Wi-Fi in your own house you have so
many different ways to do what this
machine does
that it doesn't it didn't make a whole
lot of sense to me to make a proprietary
one just for PlayStation right right
their reasoning is hey we control the
hardware on both ends so we can maximize
the potential of that connection between
the PlayStation and the and the portal
because they both are Hardware right so
we can maximize that but at the end of
the day it's still depending on how good
your home Wi-Fi is and we can assume
that we can assume and maybe we'd be
wrong to say that most people's home
Wi-Fi is pretty decent and you should
get a pretty good connection right
um but that's not necessarily the case
so for me it just felt like okay
this the price point here needed to be
the key the price point is what makes it
a paperweight or what makes it viable
now is it viable for me
I tell you this I like I said I don't I
don't get to sit in front of my TV very
often
um
but I'm
I didn't go out and buy a dual sense
Edge because again especially when I'm
sitting in front of my TV I'm not
playing the PlayStation that often you
work a lot like is your work wi-fi
stable enough to do something like this
because I think that's the better
realistic approach could you go out in
public and use this to some degree no I
can't my work wi-fi is is crap so um I
can't do it so I need a native
experience on the go that's why the the
Rog is important the steam deck was
important the switch is important like
for me I need a native experience
because the you know and it's funny
kaibots was telling me all the time how
great of a cloud streaming experience he
has and he does all kinds of different
stuff with moonlight and all kinds of
stuff and I've seen it I've seen the
place I've seen him remote the
PlayStation from his house
to my parents house using that Wi-Fi
connection and he was playing Spider-Man
and it was looking great and then he
showed me Spider-Man on PC remoteed from
his PC at my parents house and it was
next level like beautiful I was like
okay
if you have the proper song
this is a really good question that's in
the chat okay and I'll play uh King
answered this too do you think that they
will update this after the PS5 gin or
you think this is done after the PS5 no
I think if it sells well if it sells
well they'll make another one or or do
something about it if there's enough of
an outcry to make it a true Cloud thing
they'll do that I don't know that
there's enough of an outcry that can
happen for them to consider making uh
another
machine that's capable of local play I
don't know that that's ever going to be
their thing again unless again the the
next steam deck or the next Rog or the
next competitor in that space comes out
and blows everything out of water
because again when you think about it
you can't look at the switch as a metric
for a competition there because the
switch is in his own lane it's not
indicative of what the people that play
Xbox or Playstation will would primarily
would want out of sort of the handheld
thing I think you have to really think
about if you're looking at higher higher
level Tech then you have to make the
comparisons to the steam deck you have
to make the comparisons to the Rog so
they would have to make something that's
comparable in that space in that price
range right obviously so to me them
doing something like that pushes them
into making another sort of seven or six
seven hundred dollar thing right or
something super expensive like the VPS
VR2 that may not appeal to their base so
to me if it sell as well they'll
definitely make another one they may add
Cloud functionality to it I don't think
it ever goes beyond that
me I believe um Sony is just doing
enough stuff to throw it against the
wall to see what sticks
um this is a passion project
the same thing I felt that the
PlayStation VR was a passion project uh
the VR2 uh uh I don't believe they get
past this generation
and I believe this is uh I'm gonna do
everything I possibly can right now
while I can and to see exactly what's
happening so this is when you're in a
fight and you notice that the punches
that you're landing on the individual
that's in front of you is not working
and you start kicking and biting so Sony
is at the kicking and biting stage right
now and when they realize that that
won't work I think they're just you know
pack it in and just tell you hey man
we're gonna go back to third-party
developer uh could we get a contract you
know type of thing so no I don't believe
they developed this Tech anything
further as you can see with the
PlayStation VR too if it doesn't sell
they don't support and there's no
support there so it is what it is you
said that with the straightest
listen I listen to this show every week
every week I listen to this show every
week and every time you say PlayStation
is done I always say he can't believe
that but you this is the first time you
have fully convinced me that you are for
real oh no I've been for real no I know
you say this all the time but being here
with you and looking at you say that
exact how straight you just said it
before I feel like you're for real Forte
I want you to look everything that I
have been prophesizing it has been
coming to Bear everything right and what
the PlayStation owner doesn't understand
is I'm just basing this
off of Moore's Law right and Tech
this generation just started now
honestly I believe that this generation
starts in September right and I I have
firsthand knowledge that I believe it
starts in this September that this
generation starts
this game of the year is going to show
you where everything is going
I believe so
and I also believe that Microsoft after
acquiring ABK and they said they're not
done they will continue to acquire
developers that will produce games at a
rapid Pace where the competition cannot
go look at the indications Sony just
went out and got a headphones company
that's not the acquisition you guys
wanted y'all wanted a developer because
you know it's an upcoming fight if the
company shows you they're putting their
interest in other places a PlayStation
car
a PlayStation uh uh headphones company
then you see them making Preparatory
PlayStation links stuff
look where they're leading you and what
they're explaining to you
that's why you can extrapolate I don't
believe that they're all away in this
you know you can keep saying uh oh
they're they're down there you're
getting one game this year bro yeah and
they told you going forward it would be
one or two games a year
Microsoft told you when we start hitting
we're going to keep bombarding you again
they're getting more than they're gonna
make it more than a game they're getting
Gran Turismo movie too oh well I'm gonna
go probably see that right after this
but I mean it's just leaning into what I
see and it's not just oh you're a Xbox
Fanboy if I was just an Xbox Fanboy I
wouldn't have your mascot hostage
um
I I believed in what I see I didn't see
the signs as a kid that turbo Graphics
was going out of business I didn't see
the signs as a kid that Sega was getting
stomped out I didn't see signs that
Nintendo was on the brink right Nintendo
threw a hail Mary and they caught that
pass with the switch if they messed up
the switch you will not be hearing about
Nintendo except for third parties right
now I don't believe it and you're seeing
Nintendo's uh Hail Mary
Sony's Hail Mary is the PlayStation VR
and it's portable
you gotta think about that that Hail
Mary is weak as hell bro like you still
throwing Hail Marys in this way listen
let me let me let me let me finish my
point though
because I think
I think this is the the VR is definitely
the passive project like we started this
let's finish it let's put it out there
whatever it's it's nice Tech it's nice
tech for the price right
um if if it would have been PC
compatible would have been fantastic
um and there's a lot of people in the
community Doing Network right now right
right so this this though I have to say
it may not be for me I I don't think the
fomo is going to get me on this one I
might buy it used at some point because
somebody's gonna return this when they
accidentally think it's an actual poor
behind this so
your curiosity is your enemy but we'll
see but for me it really isn't for me
but I will say if there's anything that
I play very little of is my PlayStation
right I still haven't beat Ragnarok
um I still have another game yeah I
haven't beat Ragnarok so again it would
probably be something like this would
help if I was just sitting on the couch
whatever but that never really happens
so what I will say is this though
because it's priced so similarly
similarly to the Dual sense Edge
and they if they Market it as that type
of peripheral and they make it clear how
close in price point that is I think it
can have appeal beyond the hardcore that
just want this to be able to like adding
said play on the throne or play in bed
or whatever because
according to Matt biscatello right Matt
biscatella from circana formerly the MPD
group in dollar sales not in units but
in dollar sales the Dual sense Edge is
the best selling peripheral of this year
right so there people are willing to pay
the near 200 they you know for the Dual
says Edge as people have been willing to
pay for elite controllers right but it
never been 200 like the deals on the
edge is up there so this is in that
range so if they Market it as such I can
see sales going pretty well now at the
end of the day when product is in
people's homes
will they expect more from it than it's
able to do maybe right that that
confusion may still be there but I think
if they Market it right
and they focus on that price point and
they make those comparisons to do it
says Edge and people like hey wait a
minute
and like to add its point if they ever
allow you to use it as a controller for
the PlayStation itself
I think it might be able to do something
it might be able to do something
considerably more than the psvr too
right so to me it's a wait and see
because I think they didn't step on the
rake when it came to the price point
where they did step on the rig for me is
the PlayStation link and once again
closing off the ecosystem and forcing
you now from what I read you can just
plug in a a regular set of headphones
into this I guess it has a jack right
um
but again their point is oh get the buds
right get the get the elite headset
um it doesn't work with it no it does no
it's not just the buds it's both it
comes out the elite headset comes out
afterwards right
but to me I have a Pulse headset and I
think they're proprietary uh 3D sound
stuff is great on Playstation games I
think it's very crisp I think it's very
good
um
so I like that headset to see what they
do with the next gen of it cool I don't
know I'm not I'm not paying 150 bucks
for another headset it's not going to
happen so it's not for me uh but again
the idea that they're now pushing this
close proprietary thing in a in a time
when we're looking for more devices to
allow us to be able to play the games
where we want to play them how we want
to play them you know Xbox has been
touting that forever now the idea that
they continue to build stuff in this
walled off closed ecosystem doesn't make
a whole lot of sense to me man and
really that's to me an unnecessary rake
step to making people not purchase the
headsets at all right if you haven't had
the pulse right beforehand maybe you pay
the buck 50 to get that you know
whatever updates they have to the pulse
the earbuds from what I read in the
article they're comfortable they don't
look very nice they seem like they stick
out of your ear a lot like I don't know
they don't they don't look Sleek per se
so to me that's the rake step there but
the prices yeah you're right I got on it
earlier was wrong they had uh redacted
it and fixed yeah yeah so so the price
of the portal to me is they did they did
the right thing we'll see how they
Market it we'll see how excited they are
to sell it because they certainly aren't
excited to sell your psvr too that's for
sure so but I think they did the right
thing with the price point and we'll see
like I said if they Market it like a
controller like the like the edge
it could surprise in terms of sales
Okay so
I got a lot to unpack it right so
and uh this is my title uh I brought
this topic up and you guys know I was
going to go give these guys a smokes
shout out to Tom uh you were right I was
wrong uh because I
underestimated Sony's ability to uh
just flog their fan base in in the
Public Square right uh just for being
supportive
no Bluetooth in the box that's an L
that's ridiculous uh the uh what is it
the screen time on the thing the battery
life on is the same uh amount as the
Dual sense which is abysmal probably the
worst out of all hand uh controllers
that's in the market today uh is the
Dual sense when it comes to battery life
so that's a no
the PlayStation link
that's built in in uh to replace the
the Bluetooth
that is crazy
right the thought process in that is you
got a handheld that you want to be
sneaking off in the corner with so you
want to keep the the the sound down all
right cool you get some headsets either
you can pay 150 on top of it and issue
two hundred dollars or you're going to
pay 200 on top of that an issue 200
right so you're looking at four hundred
dollars walking out the store if you get
the buds you want to get the buds you
want to be you want to look cute you
want to be distinct you want to be in
the corner you want to hide it out all
right you got the buds on put the buds
in your air you go do your thing now
you need a PlayStation 5.
let's add that 500 on top of that so we
had 900 right now bro
oh how did you get the nine king oh my
math Works math and your math not math
and you thought you was walking in with
the 200 and you was in and out so let's
go to the math that's not math and then
the math that's math and my math is math
and 200 right 500 right that's 700 but I
need some air buds so that's another 200
right then we got tax so we had a
thousand dollars here
for a limited machine
this machine is going full key yes
right and shout out to K M for being
boots on the ground to actually get
their hands on it and get a chance to
see exactly what it's about and we found
out it's exactly what we hoped it
couldn't be we thought it was going to
be something nice to have the PSP a
Monica in your name you're supposed to
hold up that that line somebody in the
building is trolling us people somebody
in the building has the ability to
release this stuff out that nobody wants
why is that why would you release a
PlayStation VR and don't have the
ability to use it on the most powerful
Hardware in the world which is the PC
that has the most robust Library when it
comes to VR games to actually push your
attack why because you don't care about
your Tech being sold across the world
you just care about capitalizing on your
fan base that doesn't know any better
and you're doing it again you double
down tell me that the handheld don't
look Sleek tell me that the handheld
don't look nice that's a lot because it
looks sleek and it looks nice all right
so we got eye candy for the idiots that
follow
get it two hundred dollars oh that's a
spit in the bucket half of you probably
don't even got a PlayStation so you got
to get a PlayStation right but let's say
the dudes the 40 million that do got it
that never do support because y'all
didn't show up for the PlayStation VR so
I can't trust you guys but let's say I
do trust you guys y'all go out and get
it one of you gonna say you know what
let me go to the store and play this God
of War
ain't no Wi-fi walk into the store
so you can't play it oh let me go let me
take it and play it at my boy house oh
ain't nobody at your house for you to
call and tell them to turn on your
PlayStation 5 because if it's not on you
can't play it I had a question
if I don't have if I don't have a
digital uh Library downloaded to that
small hard drive that's on the
PlayStation 5.
and I got a lot of my games physical
because I don't trust you
how the hell am I going to play this
thing that streams from there that the
game is not completely downloaded to the
PlayStation
so they'll put physical people at a
disadvantage they didn't answer that
question so I believe if you don't
answer that question that there's a
problem there so you physical guys that
oh I love physical you're going to be
physically left out the door is going
physically close in your face
Wi-Fi this is just a streaming only and
you can't stream the cloud services be
the backbone of the new PlayStation
going forward you're releasing a new
tech that doesn't take advantage of the
new
software that you're putting in your box
is DOA this is the worst step going
forward and I think Tom had something to
do with this
um
don't let them because I can't send this
guy console so don't don't let it uh
access the cloud don't let them access
streaming what it says it's supposed to
do don't let them access what it's
supposed to do and what it's made for it
so it can show its ability to be a
champion in this space this is the worst
Hardware I thought the PlayStation VR
was going to be the worst Hardware
launch no y'all said hold my bear I got
you don't worry about it boo-boo
now here's the plot twist here's the
spin here's where king turns into King
again
I'ma probably get it
let me explain why my son said
Daddy can I play the PlayStation uh
right now because he has a PlayStation 4
he's upstairs so I was like nah right
now you know I gotta finish up this star
field I got to do as much as I possibly
can because when we talk about it I
gotta have vast knowledge of the game
and the systems that I'm using so no oh
my focus has to be on this and then um
you know I'm playing fortnite in between
he could be sitting there playing it on
that little screen
while I'm playing over here because
there's only one PlayStation 5 man I
don't need enough of those because I
don't even play that thing but he could
be doing that and that's when it clicked
in my head
wow
this is for that individual that doesn't
have the screen time and it has one
PlayStation inside the house that's on
the same Wi-Fi that's in proximity of it
that needs access to it
that's a small niche
uh group that you're counting on to
sustain the the the the product being
purchased
I don't know how you Market that but I
think they started off marketing it
wrong because it's coming out as a
Playstation portable handheld streaming
device and there's so many different
caveats that's under it but if nobody
has anything else on the topic I mean I
think I've we've all talked about it at
nauseam or what they don't have and what
they should have but you know the fact
of the matter is they don't have certain
things that can make this handheld a uh
Excel and get to where we want it to be
I think we all wanted to succeed but we
all wanted it to succeed with certain
things like Bluetooth inside the ability
to use it uh without it streaming all
the time to actually be a true handheld
and I think Sony decided that they was
going to make a compromise
they weren't going to make proprietary
discs for it because that's what you
would have to have done you know to make
a proprietary medium for it to actually
sell if you're going to make little
cartridges or you was going to make this
and they didn't want to do that but they
wind up putting some proprietary stuff
in it anyway with the PlayStation link
I think they could have did it better
and the fact that they didn't leaves me
a little bit disappointed I think they
should have just left this thing on the
Shelf until they was able to figure it
out and get a good product to the to the
masses but I think again they gouging
the fan base they're flogging you in the
town square and I have nothing else to
say about it but if anybody has anything
else to say about it before we uh get to
these super chats and get to this last
topic please speak up now
uh please let's get to these super chats
and let's get to our last topic of
BioWare
let me see we got uh stash Garden
remember for 15 months Lord bronze uh
guess they called it project Q because
of all the questions that it raises hey
yo that was good that was good
then we got Robert Kelly Super Chat the
price actually is 3.99 if you get the
earbuds yes it's not what is forcing you
get the earbuds don't get the earbuds
then we got JD gamer ten dollar Super
Chat it's possible the PlayStation
Portable is designed to be a cash grab
and confuse the market because Xbox
slash game pass is going to be on all
Portables going forward so they needed
something on the market that's crazy
yeah yeah that's that's a lot of money
to spend on on a diversion like that's
crazy
that's crazy
[Music]
uh we are all looking at it the wrong
way Sony isn't selling a 200 handheld
they're selling us 400 headphones
happy born day to Rand oh shout out to
Randolph happy birthday
[Music]
you can tweet that out hashtag free
knocker leave NACA right where he is
he's paying for his sins
then we got God Emperor Sofa King two
dollar Super Chat my question why do why
do this if they're doing Cloud push it's
very weird that this first party product
does not include Cloud where they
supposedly have this great you know push
into the cloud space where their their
Cloud stuff is getting considerably
better I don't understand
then we have wavy kosher remember for
four months Lord bronze shout out to Cog
I hope every day you're getting better
you know the room got you back no matter
how beefy it is
I know he's listening so not the car
then we have Robert kellett two dollars
to be chat damn so PlayStation's going
to be Xbox One era Microsoft
we'll see I mean I I think PlayStation's
Mo right now is we're going to give you
a whole bunch of other side stuffs so
that we could support giving you 200
million dollar first party game so we'll
see
we got Nintendo Taco 500 five dollar
super chat now 500.
that's cat King Nintendo could have
three more we use and still be standing
unlike PlayStation one of those and
they're out for good
I don't think that Nintendo could do
three of them though because we saw when
they did one I think they had one bullet
in the chamber and they shot it and hit
goes with the switch it may it may have
been presumptive to say that out of the
first party thing but they would have
really needed to come up with something
like the switch if they would have
decided once again yeah we're gonna
compete with these guys in power and no
no the market cannot hold three three
consoles they kind of do the same thing
yeah I think they moved on in four years
the Wii U came out in 2013 and they were
done with it by 2017. 17. four years
yeah yeah four years yeah so not man
they they they they they could have uh
they could have been out of it uh we got
Captain chats with the five pounds of
the chat uh Sony been riding the PS4
wave after Spider-Man it's done what
else is there no road map just VR slash
remote devices and headphones where is
the games yeah I'm assuming again
we're they're gonna hand out the
traditional Sony type titles kind of
piecemeal you're going to hear about
them further apart from one another
because like King said we're not going
to be getting a lot of those we're gonna
get one two maybe per year in that uh
you're gonna see a lot of service games
though kind of that kind of scares the
hell out of me they gonna be there
then we have Rumble Grumble five dollar
Super Chat
Odyssey makes the best headset available
for audio files I'll make it'll make all
3D audio better including Xbox the
Maxwell is hands down the best Xbox
headset yeah I almost I almost broke on
an odyssey headset probably the Maxwell
a while back and I was like I'm not
gonna do this I'm not on my consoles
enough to use it but yeah I heard they
were fantastic let's see but again
spending money on uh Audio company it's
lets you know where they're going yeah
exactly make Xbox headsets bro
yeah
I mean hey they will get that bag right
if they if they make the if they make
the best Xbox headset available they're
gonna get that money as soon as Xbox pay
like their way let's go
then we have Zay 316 five dollars for
chat even Marcus Brownlee from nkbhd
Portal
court reporter one of the most
anti-consumer products in a long time
that's not a good look for Sony
not a good looking and I could see the
anti-consumer part about it right but
the price point again I think the 300
price point would have been egregious
but they didn't do that but
um Nintendo Taco five dollars Nintendo
is Cash Rich no debt no losing money on
console sales at launch that is true
Nintendo wasn't in crisis with the Wii U
plus the 3DS was still banking very true
if they would have made another mistake
and not done a hybrid and focused on
what they were good at which is
deportable yep they they would we would
be seeing Mario on other platforms today
100 you're not gonna have two failures
of that magnitude back to back and be
like yeah we'll keep doing it because
they wouldn't be cash rich
uh let me see Texas member for 11 months
Lord bronze King your son can remote
play the PS5 from the PS4 that is what
I've made what I have mine do PSP is a
money grab okay so I'm I'm gonna see if
he can he's able to do that today if
he's able to do that today then
eliminates a 200 purchase from myself
um you know plus the Curiosity Tech dude
inside of me would have you know loved
to see it uh but again if that can
eliminate that he's upstairs I'll turn
it on but you said is this supposed to
work hold on I'm a little confused is
this supposed to work with PS4 as well
no no no no no no no
okay that I'm able to stream my uh PS5
to my PS4 right so you were thinking
about getting the portal for you
something yeah yeah because when he's
always harassing me to play the
PlayStation and he's not allowed to you
know to uh to hang out in my red room
because he made a mistake and broke a
statue so
um he's not able to be in there by
itself again so
you'll be able to play the PlayStation 5
and because the you know PlayStation 5
is in the red room floor well hang out
with me if so it's got a better one for
you king take that PS4 trade it in at
GameStop instead of spending 200 on a
portable on that portal pay like 50
bucks to get that man the digital PS5
and be done with it are you serious
yeah do that okay so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna box mine up send it to you
send the bread and we'll have a
conversation later I got the Star Wars
edition one anyway too yeah you'll get
at least you'll get close to a bill at
least for the five the four and then
instead of paying that 200 for that
portable then 100 waiting to get them a
digital five and then you done with it
that works
all right they said we caught up okay
all right last topic this is sovereign's
topic and he uh brought this to the
realm and I I didn't even know that this
was happening but uh okay so I'm going
to comic book gaming for this title all
right and uh BioWare is making some
changes while it develops the next gen
uh Dragon Age BioWare goes under re
restructuring amid Mass effects and
Dragon Age dread wolf developing this is
brought to you by CAD Honda uh from
comic book gaming BioWare is going under
some pretty big changes while it
develops what could very well be the
next two biggest games today the next
Mass effects and Dragon Age dread
BioWare is is one of the most respected
developers that's out there but their
reputation took a bit of a nosedive last
generation after releasing the
critically acclaimed at Dragon Age
Inquisition BioWare moved on to games
like Mass effects Andromeda and Anthem
both of which bomb pretty hard and were
played with their own issues ever since
spiral wear has been trying to get
things back on track both the new Dragon
Age
both the new Dragon Age and Mass Effect
games have been in development for quite
a while and it seems like it may take a
bit before they actually see the light
of day concerns have been raised about
the development of Dragon Age dread wolf
due to its lengthy development and we
still don't know when it's going to
release with that said BioWare has
announced that it's eliminating 50 roles
at the company as part of the new
long-term Vision to better support the
Studio's health and desire to craft
single player games BioWare is hoping to
move some of its effective staff to
other roles within EA but set it's
likely that it's not likely that
everyone will be able to be reallocated
so
with this being said uh Sovereign
brought this to the realm and I didn't
know EA was having these issues of well
BioWare for that matter going forward
but it does make a little bit of sense
uh do you want to start off the topic do
you want to go to somebody else and you
end off the topic
let me let me start it off let me start
okay so more sovereign
yeah so again on Wednesday they put out
a statement indicating uh and it's never
it's never good when it says and an
update on the state of BioWare and is it
today rather than discuss one of our
upcoming projects which most people you
know Gamers want to hear about it's once
you talk about the studio and and things
that we you know outlining a vision for
the future it's never a good thing so
they cut what they cut 50 jobs
um at the what we're assuming to be the
tail end of development on dread wolf
but we don't know right we really
haven't heard a lot from them recently
we don't know how much they've had to go
back to sort of rejigger that game
um I initially it was supposed to be a
very sort of multiplayer sort of driven
thing and they removed that so I really
don't know where they are in the state
of development you would hope that
they're far along enough uh where we see
that game soon
um but at the end of the day it's just
another indication that BioWare is not
the BioWare of old and I think we we've
as fans of their games I think we've
come to understand that that they're
just not the same right whether it's you
know internal strife or you know
figuring out what you know in terms of
vision for the for the studio and the
games that they make it just feels like
they've had a lot of difficulty just
being able to have a relatively smooth
development on their games right because
you know Game Dev is never smooth but uh
it just feels like the the studio has
been really marred by the inability the
sort of you know get get their games
across the finish line or just making
good choices on products we see what
happened with anthem
um so
my thing is this this sounds I really
don't know what to think of this to be
perfectly honest I really do think that
BioWare is a shadow of its former self
and it worries me what you know what
dread wolf is going to be and it wears
me what Mass Effect is going to be
um once you cut 50 people from a team
that's used to working under the EA
Banner is used to working with frostbite
because this is going to be a dread wolf
in particular is a frostbite game right
so now you're looking at
you're getting across the Finish Line
with 50 less people let's say you do
fill in some some spots with um with
contractors right that you don't have to
worry about benefits or anything like
that for them
and once again you're you're having to
fill in spots and finish out a game with
a team that isn't hasn't been there for
a long period of time maybe doesn't
understand Frostbite the way some of the
people that are being let go understand
frostbite
um all of these things once again this
cyclical sort of this vicious cycle
of sort of
roadblocks to getting this game out the
door in addition to the roadblocks
they're being placed uh to getting the
next Mass Effect out the door in a way
that is satisfactory to fans right fans
that were disappointed with Andromeda
disappointed with with Anthem uh and
very worried about what dread wolf would
be and what the next Mass Effect would
be so I'm gonna be honest with y'all I
don't know again uh okay shout out to
Colin again as Colin's been saying this
for a long time but it's just like I
don't know that it even makes sense
again maybe I'm proven wrong in the next
and Dread wolf is amazing and the next
Mass Effect is amazing I don't know
but it never looks good when you have to
come out there and say we have to cut
our these these essential roles from our
team and consolidate in order to
preserve the the strength of the of the
the dev studio for the future
um these games require a lot of people
to work on them you're talking about
massive RPGs like things that they've
specifically said themselves these are
games that are all about
um
preserving the health of the studio and
I quote and better enable us to do what
we do best create exceptional story
driven single player experiences filled
with vast worlds and Rich characters
vast worlds and Rich characters require
people time and money
and when you cut the people out you can
assume that the same amount of money
isn't there
I don't know
what kind of stance they have within EA
in terms of the leeway they have
to to you know to make you you put out a
stinker with Dragon Age red wolf or a
game
I don't know that BioWare is long for
this world
um and it's sad to see because I was
really hoping and and that they were on
the right track and seeing this
seeing this you know we hadn't heard
from them for a while so I'm like
they're good they're working heads down
they're working and they seems like
they're not really good like that so um
again disappointed because we we love
BioWare right we love Mass Effect we
love Dragon Age
um it's just it's it's kind of
disappointing to see how how far the
mighty have fallen right and maybe it's
an unfair assessment because the the
same people aren't there but still it's
the BioWare name and if you're gonna
keep using the BioWare name it comes
with expectations whether it's fair or
not yeah so that's where that's where I
stand
okay
uh Forte your thoughts on the matter
all right I'm going to read this in
order to meet the needs of our upcoming
project continue to hold ourselves to
the highest standard of quality and
ensure buyer will continue to thrive as
a industry that is rapidly evolving
um we must shift towards a more agile
and more focused Studio we will allow
our the developers to iterate quickly a
lot more creative and form clear Visions
on what we're building before we develop
it ramps up to achieve this we find
ourselves in a position where change is
not only necessary but unavoidable as
difficult as this is to say rethinking
our approach to development inevitably
means reorganizing our team to match
Studio changes that tells me that
BioWare will no longer be here in the
next five years
once once wolf releases if like like
Sovereign just said
once drip with releases
I think they're slowly downturning that
studio they're going to probably
reallocate people to different places
I just think a long development cycle
like these games have been having over
for BioWare over the course of the last
10 years is eating at just the core what
that studio has been it is nowhere near
being the same Studio even since Mass
Effect Andromeda came out is not the
same Studio every game that's released
it's been some type of downturn they
bring people like
um gager back they bring people like
Mark Dyer back they bring these people
back and then they leave and then when
they leave they take people with them
and now you're seeing downturns and just
overall
just just think about what the mental
health at that studio has to be you know
with the overall just bombardment of
criticism because you are BioWare you
are BioWare Yeah it's you're you're
nicely Old Republic your Mass Effect one
two and three Your Dragon Age Origins
one Awakening Inquisition that's who you
are
and
and that is what people always remember
them being and that's not the same
Studio no more and it hurts me being a
Mass Effect fan that the last proper
Mass Effect we got in and yes Andromeda
was a dud it wasn't a horrible game it
just wasn't what Mass Effect fans wanted
and that was the downturn in the
beginning of the end for it and I just
see this being a situation where EA is
like we're just going to start moving
these projects off of BioWare
and we're going to reallocate these
people to other places because at this
point it just doesn't seem like BioWare
is going to make it past this generation
and that's what that and honestly that's
what that
um for the general manager of the studio
that I just read that's what that sounds
like that sounds like the beginning of
the end it's accepting inevitability
that once we're done with this project
there's a good chance that this will
probably be the last project under
BioWare that we know it as of now
that's kind of crazy and just to think
about it Lord attic
um
what is your thoughts and opinions on
BioWare may not be around after this
restructuring that they're having inside
internally uh we don't know exactly the
job titles that are being restructured
but what is your assessment of the
situation from what you can see from the
outside
true and you know they're about to wrap
up shop in case the studio doesn't uh
perform in this next game I think uh
Lorraine Studios needs to buy them
I think I think that studio has the
talent and the in the the Keen Eye
to really Elevate that studio I think
that they're even at the end of the day
even if learning you how do I pronounce
them
Larry in studio even if they don't want
the talent because they feel like the
the pool's been tainted the IPS alone is
worth buying off EA and I feel like
Lorraine Studios could really Captivate
Mass Effect they I think they could do
you know a lot with that studio I think
them two together is what makes more
sense I think you know
them going off each other you know
obviously that's something they've never
done but I think those particular two
Studios there's never been two Studios
making similar games like them too
and I think BioWare has lost its way and
I think the atmosphere of Lauren is
enough to keep to get them back because
I think the bulk of the issue with this
is they've lost a lot of the talent with
with bio with uh BioWare that because of
the atmosphere of EA yeah and I feel
like Lorraine Studios is a atmosphere
that is like what BioWare used to be
so I think them two together would make
a lot more sense than them to apart you
know they could buy them merged too
because I think the IPS make more sense
because I just don't want EA shutting
the studio down and never doing nothing
with that IPA or their IPs ever again
right so I think out of everyone in the
industry laurion is what makes the most
sense yeah I mean they they fit very
nicely in Microsoft's bubble as well
yeah but here's the thing though like
I think
they need a restructure in the culture
and the type of games they make
and I don't
I think Lorraine can get them there
quicker than Microsoft does because
because they they are essentially new
BioWare right like they make the new
type of BioWare games that I think
getting them together makes the most
sense than anything else
um okay so since since everybody went uh
I'll round it up uh to finish off this
uh the final topic uh I want to give a
shout out to the
the almost thousand we had a thousand a
couple of seconds ago uh watching right
now um if it's the first time that
you're following this podcast I'm not
the normal host I'm usually uh you know
having fun in the background the
provocateur yeah yeah I'll push the
needle in my direction uh Lord Cognito I
want everybody to send their uh prayers
and well wishes to look Cognito I think
he's been released at this moment and
you know go home he's he's out going to
get his uh his pick up his medicine and
stuff like that and go home go home and
sleep sleep and rest but uh thank you
guys but now um on another note I want
everybody to reach out to Larry herb uh
his mother's past and uh just just give
well wishes out to Larry her uh one of
the finest gentlemen in the realm
um I'm sorry for your loss sir uh so uh
please uh
just a prayers to you also everybody go
say you know happy birthday to Randolph
or just hit him on Twitter I think
everybody needs that birthday love so
happy born day to Rand out Thor again uh
please uh send love and and affection
towards everyone all right
um how I feel about this Mass effects is
a huge thing for me right and when they
gave Andromeda and all the things that
were going on with the drama they were
like oh man this is that EA effect these
dudes over here not respecting us and
then you know Dragon Age Inquisition was
dope for me and
now to hear that they have to
restructure we never want to hear
restructuring we always want to hear
everything is going fine but that's not
usually what goes on in these Studios a
lot of times in the studios dudes is
fighting Crunch and you have a lot of
moving people doing this that in the
third and stuff happens listen we try to
get r r together every week and it's
usually something that happens that push
the days back and that's just only you
know two people so I can't even imagine
having Studios filled with hundreds of
people and having to juggle certain
things you know and especially you know
dealing with that stuff after coming out
of the the pandemic and how stuff was
restructured and still trying to get
people back into work while dealing with
certain things so again we're learning
how to do things differently
uh are they the same environments do I
agree with Larry and students Studios
purchasing them
to a degree maybe because the game's on
the surface kind of look like they fit
their mold but I don't think Mass
effects fits inside their whale house
yeah Dragon Age might but does mass
effects fit inside their warehouse uh
what we tend to do is see quality come
out of one Studio when we want to
bombard them with other stuff that we
love to be done with the same reverence
of their own titles sometimes that works
out sometimes it doesn't but what I do
see this year more than any other year
that we're having a Resurgence when it
comes to RPGs and I think that if EA can
get a chance to see that how Diablo 4
how uh Boulders Gate 3 how Final Fantasy
how
um Zelda and how Starfield is performing
in the marketplace how they can see that
maybe they do double down and give them
a little bit more financing and and do
these titles Justice knowing that they
can actually sell and have a long life
when it comes to a good RPG that is
highly rated on Metacritic what I'm
hoping for and then and this is Hope
Beyond hope because we know EA hasn't
shown the best uh business savvy and
knowledge when it came comes to their
own IPS what I hope
is that you know BioWare gets the actual
funding gets the actual talent and they
do allow them the time to craft good
stories a little bit bug free don't
don't say ship now just to meet a date
in order to fix patches and all that
stuff later down the road that will
inevitably hurt these games that's what
hurt Andromeda uh and you know and this
and the story didn't live up to a lot of
people's expectations there was a lot of
things that didn't push the needle
forward we're looking at Dragon's Age
and we're saying please don't let Donna
drama to us don't give us a weak story
don't give us a buggy game please put uh
you know some respect behind bioware's
name and I don't think you know biowest
had that spec respect since Anthem and
since on on Andromeda right so we just
want them to round out into form we
don't want the third game to be a dud do
they fit in Microsoft's Warehouse
I think Mass effects does uh I think
Dragon Age would be a little bit more
redundant if Microsoft was to pick up
the IEP so I would like the IP to go to
someone else maybe an up and coming
Studio that uh that needs a good title
but they have a good pedigree I don't
know uh but I do hope that the titles do
work out um the restruction is a big
concerning but I'm never one to give
Doom and Gloom when it comes to that
maybe they saw something and said let's
correct it now before releasing
something that we'll regret later and we
actually lose the fan base from the
initial people that do purchase it so
the crystal I have on it if anybody has
anything else they want to add to it
please do so if not we're going to get
to the super chats and we're going to be
trying to round out and get up out of
here the crazy parking is um
we might be thinking this is like a
negative thing which
In fairness to us when we've seen stuff
like this in the industry nine times out
of ten there there's fire we're just
seeing the smoke right it might just be
one of those things where they're like
look like
we're too bloated there's too many you
know variables or too many checkpoints
let's let's size down and refocus on
what made us us
I hope that's the case
uh but you know what time will tell and
I see people in the chat look I'm not
saying that Lauren or whatever I don't
care how you want to pronounce it
I'm not saying that I can't call it a
woman's name
I don't get Lorraine Lorraine whatever
whatever whatever I'll call it apples
and oranges for all I care all right
look I'm not saying that they have to
make a Mass Effect game I'm not even
saying they have to make you know that
turn-based style that some voters gave
three what I'm saying is the cultural
that that studio has is open to actually
letting them creatively do what they
want to do I don't think that's the case
that's going on in EA right now and you
know we we've seen that studio be very
open to letting them do stuff I don't
know if you've ever looked at anything
related to that studio their culture is
what massive Mass Effect is what BioWare
needs you know I feel like the morale
there is done that's why you're seeing
the studio deliver what they delivered
over and over again you've seen them go
through stuff like The Anthem being
printed now I wouldn't say forced to
make Anthem but you could tell that
studio that's not their Lane and I think
that they were pushed into that
direction and then they tried to make
whatever they could with that game but I
didn't remember they said that that was
their decision right they say I mean it
it fits it fits because at that time EA
was like yeah we're not focusing on
single player games right so it fits
that it came from up above and maybe it
was just the bio was it their decision
or was their developer not making those
type of games anymore this is by the way
this took the they took the L on that
one whether it's true or not but BioWare
brass did they come forward and say like
that what I'm saying is
you can agree to go through a project
what is the circumstances that led you
to agree to go through that project was
it one of those things where we're like
we're no longer interested in making
games like Dragon Age and Mass Effect
right now what are you willing to do and
that led them to to Anthem yeah what led
to the decision to make Anthem is what I
wanted yeah yeah I mean the thing is I
think they saw Destiny money I think
they saw for sure
Destiny money but see Anthem could have
been done right
yeah it's just so many things that was
going wrong and so many things that was
going right for it if they would have
took the time out and put that game in
beta like games of that service actually
do put it in beta have the community
build figure out certain things behind
it and get it done I know Forte is like
whatever let it die it was going up
against Destiny you caught those hands
someone's bringing up respawn respawns a
different thing the person that's
actually
like let's be real here like Vince is
actually running yeah yeah and I think
he's got a lot more a lot more pool than
most people in that company if he wants
to come if he wants we ain't using that
frostbite okay Vince use whatever engine
you want to use literally the Jedi does
not use frostbite none of their games
have you frostbite since he's gonna
respawn which sucks it sucks it sucks
for everything but Shooters right yeah
and it and that's the thing like so
right there you have a leg you have you
have
something going up against you but I
think the crazy thing is that EA right
now they're back on the on the train
with single player games but to addicts
Point single player action games right
and they have a couple of you know
marvel licenses under their belt now
that they're working on it they may not
be all in on RPGs though because of your
level it's it's different than making an
action game because yeah it's harder to
monetize and it's just a lot more I
would there's a different level of of
minutia work that goes into it as
opposed to making an action game right
you know there's a lot of systems and
stuff like that that again with a with a
depleted BioWare team what's the
expectation there right I I just don't
know I really do think it could be that
it could be that
they just don't fit there anymore as an
RPG studio if that's what they still
technically are right and Dread wolf
could be one of those you know straight
up action RPGs there's more action than
anything else
um we'll see but yeah I don't know man
it just if they were I would love to see
them get the opportunity to be
out from under anybody and see if if
they if they can figure it out on their
own but again
none of the people that made the BioWare
that we love are there anymore so we'll
we'll see we'll see
whoa
this brings us to the end of this uh fun
and wild podcast that started off
bananas with us turning into robots
calling putting the bad signal in there
actually I threw the Hat up in the air
like from the docks I threw it up Forte
showed up swam across the river he got
in he was swinging elbows and
body slamming people Forte let the
people know where you are where you from
what you got going on this week talk to
me I think the wife wants you to leave
now
high school graduate right there oh okay
congratulations congrats congrats
congratulations that's the first time
I've seen anyone ever in your basement
they don't Hey listen it's a big house
they
they go wherever they want they wander
in right they wander in and wander out
look she's getting shy now she's like oh
you're on camera yeah yeah you're on
camera yeah you're on camera now
people know where they can find you and
what's going on brother nah man it's
been great being here with you guys uh
love the energy you guys always bring
short one man but the show must go on
and it's always great to be here today
especially help chip in uh for myself
gaming Forte YouTube Twitter
check me out over there DPS podcast
um every Thursday night 9 p.m with the
homies little backslapping yes slow mo I
was not running this show that's why it
actually went off without a hitch today
King did an amazing listen a king did a
great job hosting the day really
appreciate everything you did Laura
beefy will be back next week or in two
weeks I should say it's gonna be awesome
to get him back over here and hear
everybody's uh
um reports on Starfield in the next week
can't wait to see that but um yeah check
us out over there and check out my Xbox
videos on gaming for today is great over
there too and I appreciate you King soft
addict guys have a great weekend we'll
see you next time blessings brother
bless Lord Sovereign sir uh holder of
the purse holder of the line talk to us
shout out to everybody for sticking
around with us after our little you know
technical four it happens it happens you
know it happens so uh thanks for coming
back to the second goal run I appreciate
everybody appreciate Forte for coming
through always with his with his amazing
takes measure takes right
to balance some of the other wild takes
we usually get on the podcast but again
uh thank you guys for coming through
shout out to cogs for getting out the
hospital getting back getting back to
100 health and yeah guys uh look out
this week
12 p.m eastern time the Lords will be in
route in in the air on the way to Pax
West to give you guys the best coverage
we possibly can over there but look out
for our discussion on yes that game that
game Starfield and look out for it will
be it will be a discussion that comes
from a number of different viewpoints
right so it's going to be a very
interesting discussion so you know I
know all those other big you know sort
of outlets out there going to be having
this no come see us come see the Lord
come see the Lords it's going to be a
lengthy conversation on our thoughts on
Starfield so come and see that and of
course uh so we'll see you in two weeks
because we'll be traveling back next
Sunday
won't be able to have a podcast but uh
again thank you guys for all the support
appreciate y'all and uh see you in two
weeks see you on Thursday and then see
you in two weeks the new improve addict
who actually saved this show who was
doing a whole bunch in the background so
a lot of times y'all don't know all
those cameras that were switching all
that stuff that was happening and the
attic was doing that stuff manually on
the Fly keeping us up to date keeping us
moving uh Lord attic let the people know
where they can find you what you got
going on this week talk to us sir
you can find me on Twitter Lord addicts
IOP first off I want to thank Forte for
uh showing up here and uh being our
fourth Horseman you know we definitely
needed that well I think King for uh you
know hosting because I I don't like
hosting uh you know me me and Dirk do a
completely different thing I don't do no
intros I do nothing we come in there we
talk about the topics that we get up at
it uh so I appreciate you not having to
do that uh you know and I want okay so
on patreon to members I'm going to be
posting sometime today where it's gonna
let you guys ask us questions about
Starfield there are restrictions uh we
can't really talk a lot about the story
uh they don't really want us to go into
that obviously we don't want to spoil it
for you anyway uh so you know but you
can ask us anything else in terms of
like mechanics anything like that we
will be recording tomorrow night I
believe Monday so we'll be recording
that so you guys have till I'll say 6
p.m tomorrow and then it's it's that
we're not I'm not taking no more
questions we will be recording that
tomorrow and then it will be going up
Thursday out of Margo I appreciate
everyone for coming through you know
because of the amount of love that you
guys give us we can get stuff like Star
fill codes to give you guys our opinion
you know if we don't have a community
Bethesda wouldn't care about our input
so
I appreciate everyone for coming through
we had over a thousand like 1100 people
definitely hit that like button on your
way out man
so
myself The Host
of the show today
told you when stars are truly in line
the real stars shine the brightest when
the lights are the hottest
and there was no way I was gonna fumble
that
um
Cog allows me to be me
right as y'all can see but when I have
to button up and I have to put on that
suit and tie and after coming and I have
to hold down the line and do what I got
to do for the team every man has his job
to play in his role to be and um I play
that role and I play my job as best as I
possibly can now you can find me on
Twitter that is King David OTW that is
King David
OTW now don't say something crazy about
that OTW that means of the world not on
the way or anything weird like that
um that's the same thing for my Xbox
account I want to thank everybody that
did show up because uh showing that you
do rock with us we dated one stream and
the fact that you came back and you
rocked with us all the way I found out
what was wrong it was it was a zoom
issue
and I saw on the board that uh people
what was is zoom was freezing
on my end
well Zoom is actually yo I just watched
ill just out Alba last night in a
thousand years of longing that's on
Amazon
uh Prime where he's uh uh uh what is
that uh a gin
go check it out it's something fantastic
if if you're one of those little
novelist people that like to read this
is a book
on the screen and you understand what
you see it what I mean when I said I
know a lot of books are for movies and
stuff like that but a thousand years of
of longing it's it's a it's a great
movie for you to check out something
that you you know watch rejects
significant other
and it's a tall tale for those people
that do want those three wishes from a
gym so definitely watch that yes and I'm
gonna watch something else right now but
I'm gonna play some some more star field
so I can have as much information ready
to go now uh attic brought up something
that was very important he brought up
that patreon members will be able to ask
questions about Starfield that we will
directly answer tomorrow night all right
one question each too but if you're a
member and patreon you can ask two
questions yeah so if you remember and
you are on patreon you can ask too so if
the link is in the description for you
to join the patreon the patreon has a
lot of stuff going on and this week we
get a chance to sit down and talk and
brainstorm because we're going to be in
the same room so a lot of our efforts
are going to be geared towards patreon
so if you see value in patreon right now
you have nothing to worry about because
I'm going to make sure I add more value
to patreon we're going to be doing a lot
of collabos with different people and I
also look forward to the kickstarter the
kickstarter is about to go up when that
Kickstarter does go up uh you just you
know join then we go live and you
understand exactly what we're going to
do going forward I'm going to try to
take the podcasting space what we do in
this space and I'm trying to take it to
the next level so uh that you know goes
in line with my vision where I see us
where I see the podcasting space going I
knew podcasting was going to change from
those little heartbeats those little
avatars being seen from the dinosaur age
to the camera age to the good
microphones to the great background you
see Forte's background you see exactly
what he's doing Forte brought into the
ideas of what I put up and he has
definitely first in that space I love
him for that and that is actual
progression so what I want to do is take
the podcast in space and take it to
where I know it's going to go and uh if
it takes me to lead the way of us all to
get there then I'm going to do so but
thank you guys for rocking out I had a
great time a little bit subdued I know
y'all wanted me to go Buckman matters on
a PlayStation handheld but Cog is not
here to bounce off that's my Run DMC
moment
um and he's not here but I try to do my
best so thank you guys for showing up
we'll see you next week I know attic is
going to send you to somebody else attic
that guy that you sent him to last week
he was so appreciative man I watched his
stream he was doing baldisgate he was
super happy he had three people in there
and all you guys showed up yeah I was
like yo we came from Iron Lords podcast
that was so dope uh please continue to
follow where uh attic is sending y'all
guys just to you know show some some
questions he likes guys he's got
wandering Dutch this week nice yeah
Duchess I guess he's just back from uh
from Gamescom yeah yeah Wanda and dust
did his thing on him him in the boxberg
boxing Burger boxing burger and gas out
there yeah oh yeah I saw guys out there
too yeah that's what's up we got one
more Super Chat I forgot to read it uh
Lobo back slap yes five dollar super
chat if dread wolf isn't a success I
don't think we will ever get the new
Mass Effect they're working on three
dubs in a row isn't recoverable in fact
especially for them uh yeah I don't I
don't think so so we'll see hopefully
that's not the case
how does that goes
peace yeah it's like I said go in there
and put in their IOP raid and wandering
Dutch's stuff man go in there and show
them love we'll talk to you guys later
peace peace